The joe rogan experience.
Yes.
Ladies and gentlemen,
my phone,
shit,
the bed officially.
Iphone six.
Don,
I think I dropped it too many times or it got scared when it saw a John Wayne
par.
My phone decided to just give up what's happening man.
Man,
welcome back my friend.
It was a very fun working out with you today.
That was very enjoyable.
Uh,
John Wayne par for those you don't know,
multiple time.
Muy Thai champion.
Very famous in the world of combat sports,
both for your accomplishments and Muay Thai and a lot of people in the UFC know
about you for you or work with George Saint Pierre.
He did a lot of training with George,
uh,
for some of his MMA fights and God to show him some of your Moitai techniques,
which I really,
um,
learned a lot today watching you explain how you do things,
you have a very specific style that,
uh,
is very uniquely your own.
Yeah,
I was lucky enough to get it's highly and to leave it for four years.
So I took the tie concept and then uh,
I'll retire from Lillian,
told you and went to boxing for a year and then I just couldn't try it on my
hands and then not like boxing,
but then it sort of got a bit style cause like the crowds a little bit older and
the Molly tie crowd really pumps up.
So I decided to come back to my again and I sort of blended the two together
with the top half of the books in the bottom half of the morning toy.
And then,
uh,
just in sort of created my own concept.
And uh,
yeah,
it's been,
been very cool with been very successful with it seems like you also,
like we were talking today,
you incorporated a lot of the way Ramon Dekkers used to throw combinations.
Who was a Dutch guy who became probably one of the most famous ever foreigners
to fight in Thailand.
One most successful and the lower weight classes especially.
Yay.
He was a based,
um,
and then because he was the first white person to beat the tires,
he was such a role model.
And I one of the felonies footsteps still to this day I still trying to emulate
everything that he's done and uh,
just uh,
to the bay,
that guy that,
that winter Thailand and beat the ties at the range sport.
It's um,
yeah,
something that I look up to him even though he's passed,
I was still in me.
I still my hero in the world of [inaudible] in the world of fighting,
there's,
there's guys who have a gigantic names at like if you were thinking about a
sport like hockey,
it would be like a Wayne Gretzky or like a Bobby or that's where like Ramon
Dekkers was most casual people,
casual fans or they're not aware of like some of the greats in this sport.
It's really unfortunate.
It's because America like kickboxing for whatever reason,
it never really caught on.
And Dana White has a really good theory and he thinks it's because that in like
the 1980s and then in 19,
like the early 19,
I guess it wasn't even the nineties like mostly the eighties,
they had that PKA kickboxing on TV,
which is where Rick Rufus came from,
who turned out to be a great fighter.
But a lot of those guys were sloppy boxers
who had to throw a certain amount of kicks per round like you would do,
would make you throw at six,
seven kicks per round.
I forget what the number was.
And so they would throw like these little flippy kicks with no power and then
they would just kind of sloppy box Benny Benny the jet and Peter Cunningham,
uh,
who else?
Peter Sugarfoot Cunningham,
he became successful outside of PKA.
He did Moy Thai.
He fought a lot of different styles.
He was a more complete fighter.
I think there was a lot of fights that they had on an ESPN at two o'clock in the
morning and watch these two white dudes kickbox and you're like,
what the fuck?
I watch.
And it just,
it just wasn't at the level that it's unfortunate that people,
some people still have that in their mind when it comes to kickboxing or to Thai
because in other countries like especially in Holland and uh,
you were one of the guys who carried it over to Australia at a very young age.
It's very popular over there like in Australia exports more showing the flights
at least once a week and then that one that was from 1996 and up until last year
and then they've just stopped showing the broadcast nail and nail.
UFC has flooded the market and uh,
there's no exposure for the key books anymore.
It's hard for us to shine.
Neal really because of the MMA.
Yay.
We'll UFC,
he's there doing the paper views and they're doing the roads to the UFC and the,
they're showing all the replace every time you put the Fox sports on this just
saturated the market and there's no real,
if I was a young fighter nail and a,
they say,
what would you want to do?
Do you want to keep books at him?
UFC,
UFC for sure.
Because look at the superstars,
whereas Moitai there's,
there's no,
um,
elite,
so of a place to go anymore.
The K dead before it was k when the cable was the dream.
Right.
And now that's disappeared.
So there's glory,
glory,
glory.
Glory is amazing.
But it's not what Katelyn was.
If that makes sense.
It's still still look at UFC.
You look at the joy Saint Pierre's and the John Jones's lifestyles.
It's like holy shit,
that's a different Lee.
That's,
that's uh,
that's pretty cool.
Yeah.
It's,
well the world champions there that that level is and silvers and the,
the,
the rock and the sports cars and the,
they're on the,
they're,
they're amazing.
What you can look at it that way.
Yeah,
I guess so.
I think that,
um,
technique wise,
uh,
the,
the kickboxing world is at a very high level though.
Yes.
My world.
Very,
very high level,
which is what was missing like when they were putting on ESPN,
which is too bad.
It's cause it's like the,
if you watch glory,
like the level of fighters there,
it's a very high level of fighter.
You know,
but it's just that people are just not aware of it yet.
Yeah.
We need the media exposure.
Um,
say for the Jerry Schilling six for example,
uh,
if you would need the gay Talese house and seeing what he needs to look a person
instead of just seeing the bill ring,
how does he put his hand up?
Right.
And then he disappears.
Whereas the UFC,
um,
I know everything about George Saint Pierre without even meeting him.
I know thing about Jon Jones without meeting him.
I know everyone.
And then when they fight,
I feel I have that emotional connection an
I really want to cheer for that guy because I feel like,
uh,
I'm emotionally involved.
Whereas whereas they had the glory guys,
like I can't tell you who's who and who,
who,
how many daughters he has or what kind of pets he has at home.
Um,
one of the things that I really love about just striking about,
I'm obviously a big fan of MMA,
but when you got to think about takedowns and when you have to think about
submissions and,
and there's,
there's so many different things that you know,
a fighter has to consider.
They're not as open with their striking,
their,
they don't have as many,
uh,
moments to just freely exchange without worried about being taken down.
So,
and when you watch like real high level Moitai real high level kickboxing,
you get to see this next level fluidity and this next level technique.
And just,
I mean you see it in boxing as well.
Like I had conversations with people that say like boxing is better.
You never see people land those combinations in the UFC.
And I'm like,
well it's because they're going to take you down.
It's really,
you can't stand sideways with your shoulders like that against a really good
wrestler cause they're just going to shoot in and take you down.
But that style against someone,
if you make that agreement like it's only going to be stand up,
it's only going to be hands.
You get to see the really high level,
the Manny Pacquiao is the Floyd Mayweather is you get to see this just next
level technique.
And I feel that same way with kickboxing,
I feel like with more time with kickboxing you don't get to see the real high
level stuff unless it's just too straight pure strikers in a more time match.
Um,
when I got the opportunity to work with George,
for instance,
the first time that we spot,
I think it's Georgia,
so used to throwing winter these one,
two threes and then uh,
I was literally chasing him from one side of the cage,
the other doing a youtube and then going straight back at him again.
And then after the spy he told me guys felt like I was sparring full guys at
once because it was just relentless today
playing around today,
there was no there,
it's just continuous because there's no,
there's no theory means taking down.
So I can,
I can stand in the pocket and just keep punching in and punching and punching
and punching.
Why was,
I've always equated it to like a conversation.
Like if you have a very crude grasp of the language and you try to have a
conversation with someone,
it can be very frustrating because you're searching for the words.
They don't know exactly what to say,
who are trying to figure out what that person's saying.
But if you're like you or me who speak English very fluently,
you and I could have a conversation we don't want,
we could rattle them back and forth.
Well you're that way with striking.
You could tell like striking is like a part of your body's language.
So you're,
it's so normal to you.
You're so used to it that the,
the,
the combinations just flow like water.
Whereas like you were trying to teach me some things today about the,
the really the unique style that you have of like when you were trying to teach
me that uh,
that crazy power jab and then the setups to those knees.
Like you have a very specific way of moving and I was trying to emulate,
but to you this is ingrained in your nervous system for you,
it just flows out of you,
you know?
Yes.
I've spent my,
that's why I kind of got MMA because I've spent my whole life lending stand up
and I'm in Fia that Yo,
I have this been that a lot.
I'm on my back if I want to reach the same sort of level and I wouldn't do it
unless I had that perfection on the floor too.
So yeah,
10 years,
at least,
at least 10 years.
I've invested a 2025 years of standup,
striking alone and,
and I don't have any other hobbies.
This list is my life.
All I do is go to the gym and come home.
And then what do you do for fun?
Well,
I just,
that is my fun her and you have to do anything else.
I don't surf.
I don't bride motorbikes.
I don't do anything besides watch UFC and trained myself.
It's my life and I love it and I wouldn't change it for nothing either.
Do you have any desire to train Jujitsu just for fun?
Just for a goof?
No,
no.
That's why I come up with the Cajun way tie idea.
Because I want to fight in the cage and I want to experience a little gloves,
but I didn't want to learn that the,
the,
the ground because as,
as,
as much as I respect it,
I'm not good at it and I want to be at a high level.
So we do promotions in Australia,
radio between me and my wife as well.
Why can't,
instead of hiring a ring,
why don't we just hire a cage?
So our um,
studied a little bit on the youtube and I seen it then before and they were
boxing gloves and I thought,
well how am I going to get the respect from the MMA crowd if I wear boxing
gloves and they wear little gloves,
right?
I'm going to look like a pussy.
So I thought,
well if I'm going to do it,
I'm going to do it properly.
I'm going to wear the MMA gloves just to show you that I'm just as a warrior,
as the MMA guys are,
so say five with them.
We've done five shows and it's,
um,
it's,
it's amazing.
That's interesting that you say that because I can't imagine you would have to
feel like you at this stage of your life with all your accomplishments that you
still feel like you have to prove yourself every time.
I still now,
I still don't believe I'm there yet.
That's hilarious.
That's actually hilarious.
I mean,
you ever look at your own resume yet,
but want to pull it up real quick.
Let's pull it up at work.
So I'll just,
I'll just let you know what you've done.
Just like feel better.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm quite content where I'm at,
but it's always feels like I want to be more famous.
Uh,
that's a word.
Yeah,
no.
Well it definitely makes it makes sense.
I mean,
just,
I get that.
I mean,
all high level athletes will tell you that they're never satisfied.
Yup.
And I guess when you see guys fighting with striking with little gloves and you
see that you're using the larger gloves,
maybe that just makes you feel like you have to show that you're capable of
doing that as well.
Yeah,
I have the highest cause cause like I said before,
I,
every weekend I'm invested in the paper view on UFC.
I'm watching the reruns and I can tell ya who,
like last night for instance,
who was fighting who two years ago,
who won that flight out to such and such like,
um,
I'm so involved that it's sort of taken over my life,
the UFC even on my Moitai UFC sort of such a big part of me.
Neil.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
it's hard to explain when you read off your titles,
it's almost ridiculous.
Tet,
this is hilarious.
Oh,
wk world middleweight title Wk
BFK one middle weight world champion,
Wk Thai boxing world middleweight championship,
Wk Wk and Thai boxing world super welterweight champion International Kickboxing
magazine champion Wmc contender Asia runner up WMC Thai boxing Middle Weight
World Champion k one man is hilarious.
K One Max World Final Eight Wqa Kba k one world welterweight champion,
k one world Max world final eight Thai boxing world middleweight tournament
champion.
It just goes on and on and non Australian boxing middleweight champion King's
Cup tournament champion.
It's like over and over and over and over and over.
The fact that after all these accomplishments and he's still feel like you have
to prove yourself.
Yeah,
like I said with the the UFC,
like I see the Georges and the join James's and it's like,
why can't I can be that guy?
I want to be that guy.
You mean that guy?
Meaning getting the respect or getting the adulation of getting the,
the focus on you that these guys are getting the EA and this would have been
pretty much,
it's crazy because if you watch it,
I've always said this,
it's not like the product isn't there.
I'll give you watch high level Moitai and I watched a lot of your fights last
night after we did the podcast together.
I went back and this morning I watched the documentary on your life,
which was amazing and I watched some of your fights and you know,
uh,
the,
the product is there.
That's what's crazy.
It's like,
it's a dynamic,
exciting product.
I'm a boxing fan,
but if you give me a chance between watching a choice,
rather between watching high level boxing and watching high level Moy,
Tai,
I'll tech high level more tie all the time because the possibilities are more
the knees,
the elbows,
the high kicks,
leg kicks,
all those things together.
It's more dynamic,
there's more things going on.
So there's no reason why people shouldn't know about who you are.
I mean,
that's what,
it's weird.
It's weird.
Yeah.
My,
my,
my popularity on the social media,
it didn't explode until I started training George and then everyone said it.
Oh,
hang on a second.
Who's the split?
Was He teaching George headed?
And then from there is that open up avenues and then,
uh,
before that I was just a Yay.
Just that.
Then I did the exposure isn't that they're,
I guess they're like,
yeah,
this new opportunity.
It's exactly where the UFC was at one point in time.
I mean there was a a time in the 90s when the UFC was banned from cable when the
UFC was only,
you could only get it on direct TV and a fucking,
nobody knew who it was.
I mean I was on news radio,
which was a sitcom in America and I was starting to do the interview is that
post fight interviews and I would tell them that I would do it and people would
look at me like I'm ruining my life by being involved in this nefarious
adventure to go and watch people fight in a cage.
Like,
like,
like I was going to go watch lions fight to the death or something.
It was just,
it was weird.
It was like,
like you were talking about porn or even worse than porn.
It was like animal porn or something.
It was,
it's strange,
but now it's a,
a normal,
like if you tell people the UFC,
oh,
I've seen that.
Even if the casual person is aware of its,
it's
gotten into the public's eye enough where the casual person is it,
you know,
it's,
it's a part of this is like geist moit ties,
not I um,
I had an opportunity to fight in Thailand and a,
it was an eight man tournament and had to fight three times in two hours and it
was,
it was live on TV and it was,
it smashes build up and a I,
I fought three times and I beat the,
the Russian,
the fringe.
I beat a tie in the final,
I won a world title and million baht,
which is about 35,000 and I want to try food from the prime minister of
Thailand.
And I got back to Australia and I rang the,
the Brisbane newspaper and there's a big newspaper in Brizzy and then they've
come around and then I've just won this.
And then this prime traveling from the prime minister and the lady on the other
end said,
well,
it sounds like you're exaggerating all this.
Um,
why don't you just try your local newspaper and hung up on me before I even got
a chance to say good boy.
She was like,
and it's like we,
we only deal in football and cricket here in Australia.
Um,
and because it's not a mainstream sport.
Yeah.
Just try your local paper.
Hopefully they'll do something for you.
That's hilarious.
That cricket as a mainstream sport and what ties welcome to Australia.
I don't mean to be rude if you're a cricket fan cause I lock a lot of stupid
shit.
I'm aware.
I'm like,
I'm a,
I'm a big fan of professional pool.
I like watching people go,
you really Wa,
you know,
you're not even playing it.
You Watch it.
Yes,
it's true.
I watch stupid shit.
But Cricket Australia,
we play India.
Um,
probably once a week.
Every weekend that makes the back page,
the front page,
the six 30 news,
the limits,
the main story every single day and such and such is the Bowler Mako class got a
sore leg and then wirelessly interviewing Marco clock,
all this interview,
the answer like,
God,
this is,
and then one game lasts for days.
And so you can imagine the game last four days,
how many hours did they play?
Four.
Oh,
oh,
oh day.
They,
yeah,
they rock up in the morning and they,
they,
they go.
And if they're not out there,
just keep going and going and going.
And it's,
it's tedious.
Why not?
You know what?
I know how to fix it.
Incorporate Moy,
Tai and cricket.
So like if you strike out,
you just fucking Duke it out.
Take off that stupid fencing helmet where it's,
I don't,
I just said,
well,
it sews baseball.
Baseball's kind of silly to,
and it's our national pastime,
but when you start using that paddle,
you know,
like that fucking boat or that they smack that ball where it's,
I just,
I don't know,
I don't get it.
But then the guys in the suits,
the politicians in Australia to the cage is still illegal in Melbourne.
I still,
they've just bandit in Perth in Western Australia banned it now about a year
ago.
It was,
it was okay.
And then I've just come around and then they've been,
and I have a cage in my gym and it's like just step into a cage.
The realize how the safe and protected is compared to a ring.
Once you step,
once you step into it and appreciate what it is for what it is,
um,
you'll understand that it's so much better than falling out of a ring.
That's a meter and a half hallway.
Yeah,
the ring is not the best for MMA for sure.
But I think for striking think so as well,
because of the clenching and the throws and all that stuff.
I've seen more people fall out of a ring,
then I'll never had a cage of course.
But,
but dad with this guy's pulling out all the time.
I've seen the Dylan last time you were here,
uh,
he's not on camera right now.
There any,
hey Dylan,
what's heading it?
I don't know if he'll turn that on a Dylan reznikoff I said that right,
right.
I said,
all right.
You see what was brother Liam a while back was like a year ago.
You guys are here,
but in there,
there we go.
You guys showed a video of this dude who,
uh,
he was,
like running and attacking and he went flying out of the ring,
right?
Denver.
This rainbow was it?
They had Lynn Peeney was that he was you guys that showed that video,
right?
Wasn't it navy?
He might've been.
Tim had so many said as he's falling out of the ring,
he puts his hands at the,
the brace.
He's full.
He puts a hand on the eye to eye check.
He chain the chairs split.
No,
it pulls straight on.
He's nick.
Oh No.
And then he,
I think he was in a coma for like a month to two because he fell from about two
meters high.
He fell at the top row.
Say incorporate that from the ring to the concrete floor.
Uh,
do you remember back in the day they used to run nom events cause the cage is
banned in New South Wales.
All your waste you're in Queensland,
sorry.
And I think it was tiny Brunello show and then they used to have not out of a
cage.
So what they did is that the platform and they had all the big boys like Tama to
Hoonah and Jamie to her and and all those boys standing around at the kick
shields and guys are just getting catch guys.
Yeah you guys are getting like dropped in the heads.
We hit in the side and this is madness.
This Friday they used to push physically push guys back in and I think,
I think it was a Paulo Filio once caught some guy in a triangle through the
ropes.
He like he had his,
his,
the guy who was somehow another the trapped in the rope.
There was a limb out of the rope and a limb in a rope,
so the rope of the triangle was involved in the triangle.
Hey,
I mean the rope of the ring rather was involved in him securing the triangle.
It was like the guy was like tight tangled in it,
like that's not good and that that stop,
start,
stop,
start dragging back in the and that's on your Alma was here,
this or and go.
I've been in,
I've been talking about this for a while,
that if they can have a big room for basketball,
a big flat service,
why can't they have a big flat surface for fighting where everyone can see what
the fuck's going on because you're,
you don't see what's going on.
A lot of times with the cage,
even me,
like I'm right there when I'm calling UFC fights,
but sometimes a post is in the way or it's around,
there were like a sideway like I have to lean up to try to see because it's like
kind of like I'm looking sideways through the cage.
I think that a flat surface would eliminate a lot of the stalling and a lot of
the,
uh,
you know,
the,
the pressing,
the clinching up against the cage,
like clenching and a center is a totally different animal.
And when you're leaning on someone pressing someone against the case that it
takes out a large factor.
Yep.
Um,
and do you think about that?
And then that's possible.
I reckon that's fantastic.
You wouldn't be at a cage walk either with your shoulders in the center of the
sound.
You've got to fight for it.
You got to actually fight for it or learn how to fight off your back.
It'd be hot.
Yeah.
I mean there's guys that are really danger,
like trials all of is one of the best in the UFC at fighting off of his back.
He saw his last fight with Jeremy Stevens.
I don't know if you're aware of him,
but he's got a vicious guard.
His guard,
he's attacking all the time.
So when you take that guy down,
it's no fucking picnic.
You know,
he's,
he's constantly threatening your arm,
your neck,
and those guys are going to excel in a world where you can't just,
you can't just hold a guy against the cage or if you take a guy down,
he can't just wall walk.
A guy is going to have to fight off of his back and I feel like that's more,
more honest,
you know?
I mean the cage,
the cage is a real element of MMA and guys train for it and therefore you should
be able to utilize it.
If you're a professional,
you should understand it,
but it also puts a weird taste in people's mouths.
Like,
oh,
they're fighting cages or animals.
It's awesome.
I love it here.
I live in,
they're mad men.
Even either vote we do with the CMT,
the cage stuff.
Soon as they closed the door,
it just seems like a chew and you opponent and the,
the,
the black of the fence just makes it like a black wall.
So you can't see the crowd,
you can't see the judges.
It's just feels like the,
the arena.
It's just you and him.
Yeah.
That is cool.
That,
that aspect of it too.
Um,
but I just feel like visually,
like as far as like for being able to see,
it's not the best ring.
It's better to see 120 fights in the,
Oh,
115 flights in a,
in a ring.
And then in the cage,
it just feels like you're,
it's all,
it's you again.
It's all fresh.
It's all exciting.
So That's interesting.
That's why I love it.
So just,
just changing the environment.
Yay.
You made it all totally different for you and the little gloves,
the full him little gloves,
little gloves,
and make it more real.
Did you ever do kickboxing where there was no elbows,
like glory style,
no elbows and one of these no clinch default Katelyn for a couple of years in
Japan.
And then,
um,
when I first started it was an immature,
of course I just thought had babies and baby steps.
I did the eight count rule back in the day we had today keeps above the waist if
they didn't want to go to the PKA stuff.
PK,
they,
we do that since you did that with no,
uh,
no leg kicks and the only,
once I only went there was like Hexion bolts but leg kicks in school that had to
be above the waist.
They get the,
the count they didn't want boxing to,
there's so many guys that are doing karate that changed over the kickboxing
boxing that changed over the kickboxing and said they wanted to eliminate the
hands and make more guys kicked more.
So it had to be at least eight keeps above the waist but you still lucky.
That's interesting.
Um,
so you could still debilitate a guy and it wouldn't count point wise.
That's kind of crazy.
Yeah.
Australia.
So what is the role with glory?
Like they let you throw needs but you can't clench when you throw a knee or k
one had it for you could only clinch with one or hand for awhile.
Yeah.
2004 you were lonely as you are busy in the clinch that let it go and then bore
cal came along and just dominated everybody.
He was throwing them around like rag dolls and he busted up merge Massada I
remember Masato and then um,
say the very next year and I,
okay,
we've got a new rule one hand,
one knee and then that gives the guys that are proper,
um,
more boxing orientated.
I an opportunity to fight guys like workout where they had no chance before.
Well Alistair over too.
He used to just clinch guys with those gigantic fucking tree trunk arms.
Just hold on your neck and your Donesville he just blast those knees into you.
You ever seen a,
that fight that he fought?
I forget who it was,
uh,
to Sherra where he,
he hit him,
he clenched with both hands behind the neck and hit him with a knee and it
looked like he got shot.
Like someone hit him with a sniper bullet,
boom.
It just goes down.
You know that that clenched though is such an effective weapon.
It just,
it doesn't make any sense to me to eliminate that when I see it being eliminated
in kickboxing in or making guys,
you know,
we'll use one hand or something like that.
I'm like,
that's so,
it's so foolish.
It doesn't make any sense to me.
It's like you eliminating a really exciting aspect of,
and a crucial aspect of the art of Moy Tai.
Yeah.
The ties are so efficient in it.
They're,
they're so good and so powerful.
And you can see the shots and you can see that.
You can hear the noise bell in western Westerners get into the clean sheet,
sort of like a two dogs that are trying to make puppets.
It's not quite
hilarious.
The referee gets a bucket of water to get off each other to a male dog.
Yay.
That's funny.
That's why eliminate because are the western is aren't very good at the toys
when they,
they get able and as it throw knee for knee.
Um,
yeah.
So that made it more entertaining for the crowd,
I guess.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
I think even the crowd,
like that's one of the things that drives me nuts about modern MMA is standups.
When,
when guys get taken down and they're fighting on the ground and then they get
stood back up.
I mean,
I just,
I just think it's ridiculous.
Like if you only have five minutes,
especially me coming from a Jujitsu background,
if you have five minutes and you take a guy down,
it's a lot of times it's a slow progression to a submission and you,
you know,
you can't be like,
you're like,
come on guys,
let's work.
Let's work.
Like they're fucking working.
Okay.
But sometimes when guys are working,
it's a stalemate.
Like sometimes you're trying to pass the guy trying to stop you from passing.
You tried to advance on the other side.
The guy tries to stop you from the other side.
Like there's,
there's a lot of shit going on.
There's a lot of shit going on and uh,
unexperienced referees or referees that are unexperienced in grappling or
referees that are easily influenced by the crowd.
Like sometimes they'll hear booing and you know,
you just see what are you going to,
there's this show for assholes.
You know,
people who don't understand fighting,
you're going to stand them up,
stand them up during them up.
Okay.
Stand them up.
No,
these guys are trying to fight.
Elite XC was the worst example of that big country.
Roy Nelson had Andre Arlovski down inside control working at Kamora and they
stood them up.
Oh,
it was fucking ridiculous.
They had like a 15 second thing where if you went to the ground,
if something didn't happen in 15 seconds,
they stood you up.
Saying same sometimes
when the UFC as well,
when they press against the cage and there's this stalemate,
we absolutely nothing's
happening at all,
I think.
I think that's the same as the Moitai.
Have you pushed him against the ropes and you're holding holding and you're not
throwing anything?
All right then.
Then you've got to do it,
but if they're busy for sure.
Let it go.
Keep it going.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I just don't think you ever see that with high level guys.
I think that's just a part of being a fighter who's not that good or a fighter
who's learning while you see a guy like Cain Velasquez,
Cain Velasquez never gets worn to keep moving.
You know?
He's fucking punching you in the face.
He's taking you down.
It's like he's constantly in motion and that's why he's one of the elite of the
elite.
You don't see that stalling,
that really stuck,
you know that kind of stalling on high level guys.
Yup.
I just think he got to let them fight.
It's ridiculous enough like five minutes is a small amount of time for a
grappler.
You know,
and sometimes guys just are trying to work techniques and they're getting,
they're getting you know,
stalled out or they're getting um,
someone's using good defense and the referee just stand them up like,
well that's what Jujitsu is all about.
It's all about the guy defense and you try a different way.
Die Defends.
You need to try to keep hammering at them until he can't keep the rhythm up and
then you advance and then eventually you catch them.
But sometimes you'll be,
the guy will be defending like a wizard.
Like if you watch two guys roll too high level guys like it is like we were
expressing before,
it's like a conversation there.
They're arguing about shit and they're trying to find holes in each other's
game.
And it'll go on where it looks like as a stalemate for five minutes,
but save like it's like a Marcello Garcia character and he's fighting a guy who
was really athletic and you think you go,
man,
is how long can this guy hold Marcello off?
And that's really what the question is.
It's not a matter of,
Oh,
this guy is just as good as Marcel.
Not really.
No.
Eventually he's going to figure out the right combination of things to do to
this guy and he's gonna have his back.
And then once he has his back,
that guy's fucked.
But it's like how long does it take to get them there?
And in an MMA halfway there,
you're like,
boom.
Stirred them up,
stirring them up.
Well,
you're never going to see the most high level practitioner succeed if that's the
tactic.
You know,
you're never gonna see it.
Get to that point,
and I think that's unfortunate about MMA today,
is that they still have that standup thing.
I think standup's are,
I think it's a travesty.
I really do.
Even in Thailand and say,
say we kicked three rounds in the pads of five ends in the peds,
that that's a 15,
20 minutes,
but then every afternoon you spending half an hour in the clinch work in the
knees nonstop for half an hour.
I said they're spending more time working on that.
Then they actually kicking and punching things and then when it's time to come
to the,
when the toys got to Europe and stuff,
all of a sudden it was like a,
uh,
one knee combination before they break it up.
So they'd taken away.
My name is Sandra,
their tools.
That's an interesting thing you were talking about last night about Moy Tai
scoring that the clinching is like a big part of the scoring.
Whereas we look at clinching is stalling out or like,
you know,
something that they're doing where they're trying to like wait by their time
figuring out what to do next.
Like in Thailand,
it's a big aspect of,
of the,
yeah.
Um,
this morning we mentioned it as well.
Uh,
the Brown one,
if they don't get in the clinch,
none.
One bits,
no one bets until halfway through round two.
All of a sudden they get into the a clinch and then it's like boom,
the,
you see the,
just the hands go crazy cause everyone's their own bookmaker in Thailand.
So,
so everyone's doing their own odds and then they won't bit until they know the
other guy's got a solid solid base or a solid because what was so wild that's so
wild.
The difference in their culture is so amazing.
It's just I really have to get over there.
It's one of the things I want to do on my bucket list is go and watch a stadium
fight in Thailand.
Like a real high level fight.
Watch the,
you know,
be there for the whole night getting check it.
I'm almost willing to take a family vacation to Thailand and talk my wife.
And you're going to Thailand because that's what probably a fucking email and
say.
So the boxing hardly score lake keeps doing school and only body kicks,
knees,
elbows,
body kicks,
knees and elbows and leg kicks.
Don't,
Harley's score legs keep things cool cause it's so easy to throw a lake.
Anyone can throw leaky but it's,
it takes a high level to land a solid.
Even if it kicks the arms,
that's considered a a point as well.
If you do,
if you get kicked in the arms without attempting to try and block it,
that's it.
That's a free point.
How many guys get arms broken in Thailand?
Uh,
I haven't seen many.
No.
That's amazing cause it's really common in MMA.
I seen him go,
I get his thigh brogue.
That was pretty crazy.
Whoa.
It was hectic.
I seen he,
he hit the ground and then he was on his side and he went to rollover and he's,
he's hip went first and then his leg went second and I was like,
oh that's broken for sure.
And the next day,
sure enough,
completely snapped in half.
Had to get the pins.
It,
it's all in the magazines.
It was,
um,
it was very nice.
The analytic data,
you have to get the pins and Thailand,
hey,
it's really good.
Thailand,
the hospital,
the hospitals are more hygienic than now in Australia.
Oh,
well that's not good for Australia.
I need,
I need off the floor at a hospital in Thailand for sure.
Really?
So they have really good,
which just pretty amazing.
Yeah.
American asshole that I am.
Um,
so what did he get his leg broken?
Windows.
A cat.
Yeah,
the guy just born.
We just chopped it hard.
Damn man.
Yeah,
just snapped.
It was a very,
do remember Stan longe anitas versus Dennis Lexia.
Yes,
I do.
Yeah.
It was a big of the big hype in Australia.
That was massive in the last 15 seconds.
Stand the man that was,
he had a motherfucker of a leg kick.
Che's Christ.
Yes.
God Damn.
He used to work with my French Shuki Shuki for Magiro Gym.
Okay.
Shuki uh,
had a,
um,
he was from Israel and he had a gym out here in Encino and uh,
he was,
he was set up for a hip replacement from fucking holding the pads from Stan
longe.
Anitas Huh?
Holding that,
that five pad.
He said,
that motherfucker would kick me so hard that it would like,
it was like jolting his hips had fucked up the inside of his hip.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Wow.
Fuck heavyweights.
Kicking you,
dude.
Fuck all that.
Stan was,
he's a big guy,
right?
Uh,
he's not very tall.
He's only about my height,
but the boy,
and then,
um,
that was his main weapon was the delay kicks of the hands.
That was a first round kick too.
I mean that was amazing.
That was amazing.
The whole Napa guys femur with one leg,
the whole hype.
And then maybe he books are coming out and then us Alexia,
he was the king back then to say this was stands,
hottest fight.
And the,
the big lead up and then the,
the Soledad arena.
And then,
um,
then,
uh,
Dennis Lexia commit in the grass skirt,
that Hawaii thing.
Yeah.
That he was thinking that was gonna help the impact for the psychic.
So they have a bit of cushioning,
but it sort of reversed on him.
He,
cause he checked it,
it was a chick.
He checked it and then he went to put his foot down.
That's when he's like Shane's snipped.
Wow.
That was his shin.
It wasn't just thought three by three shinbones God damn.
Wow.
I didn't know why did I think it was the thigh bone and it was so long ago.
They did a story on it because as he put his chick checkup,
he's put,
he's uh,
incident with his foot on his knee.
So there was no give instead of having the leg fluffy and then he's,
he's locked in into his other leg and then as he's kicked through it was like
kicking,
throw a baseball bat.
Oh,
I see.
all kind of down it done.
The done the Anderson Silva,
the blip.
Wow.
That's amazing.
It's rare that you see it on two high level guys like that where you see a leg
break luck,
that maybe protein injectable protein like you really mean protein.
Did you see his fight?
Um,
Dennis.
Lexi was fight with Don Wilson as when he got schooled on leg kicks.
No Dude.
Back when the day when the dentist's Lexio was a young man,
he wasn't schooled in the ways of the low kick and he fought Don the dragon.
Wilson and Dawn Wilson fucked him up with low kicks.
Huh?
Defense and low kicks.
Yeah.
There's a guy that doesn't get enough credit.
Don Wilson had sort of like a weird sort of karate style,
but he knew how to through good low kick.
You know,
he,
he was a very crafty fighter.
Yup.
Um,
Jeez,
we're going back in time now.
Now we're in the 80s.
I think I need to go before then you go to,
you know,
you got to go to where we talked about earlier.
It's Dennis a superfood and pointless.
Oh yeah.
But there was something,
not just Dennis,
let's go a,
you go dawn Wilson and then you go Benny or keyed his or Ketos was fucking shit.
Yeah.
I trained at his gym.
When I first moved to La,
there was a first place I went to,
I was like,
I'm going to the jet center,
one of the way along pain,
say bed,
which he knows his stuff.
What about the foot things that you want to wear?
The foot cushion.
But my first fight was,
um,
the Shin pads with the foot questions and spy with a foot questions too.
So that they were,
they were in back then when,
when Chuck Norris had that world combat league and he was doing a very similar
thing to what we're talking about where they fight like kind of in a,
a small bowl,
like a saucer.
Like they didn't have a ring and they didn't have a cage.
They had just this sort of slightly elevated platform that had a lip to it.
So when they get to the outside edge,
you know,
the referee would bring them back in.
And I thought it was a very smart way to do it.
Did you think about fighting in that at all?
Uh,
I was still a puppy.
I'm only,
I was only a few years ago.
Yeah.
Mainly not,
you're only to add,
ain't no,
you're 38 now,
right?
Yeah.
We could
tell people you're not a check.
Um,
but that wasn't that long ago.
You had to be like that was,
well the guy,
I don't think it was 10 years ago,
I think world combat league was like,
I want to say it was like,
I know I was working for the UFC at the time because I went to see one live.
Okay.
And uh,
I got a hug from chuck motherfucking norm
back in the day.
I was so mad that I didn't get a picture of it.
And you lived,
yeah,
I did.
I lived,
I felt different though.
It's like I touched a lightning bolt and you got pregnant.
I might have.
Um,
but so you didn't,
you didn't think about fighting.
Okay.
What Katelyn was the dream,
right?
Caitlin was the,
the,
the Pinnacle,
the pinnacle if you'd say,
um,
that was a bummer that that kind of folded under.
I was trying to get the UFC to by k one a long time ago.
And the number one thing that I talked to Dana white about,
he's like,
ah,
people don't like kickboxing.
That PKA karate ruined it for everybody.
And I was like,
that's so crazy that to say that because like that's like saying that like UFC
one ruined it for like what we're seeing today because this is so not related.
Like the product itself,
they,
the kickboxing product itself was so high level.
When you go to the fights,
the,
the classics,
the Peter Arts fight,
the nd Hook,
you know the Mike Bernardo,
those,
those fights,
those fucking Jerome Le Banner,
those were crazy fights.
I mean if you look at that product,
I couldn't imagine anybody not wanting to put on those fights.
Yeah.
The production level to everything was high definition.
The slow is the highlight packages they'd make up you,
you couldn't help but feel like this was the,
I was lucky enough to fight there in 2004 2005 and we'll pull in 40,000 people
every show that's and in,
and we had a live 40,000 people and that you'd walk out to the arena and then
you check out the stage and sometimes you come up through the flow for your
walkout or,
yeah,
it was just unbelievable.
They had like some elevator that would make you rise up through the floor.
I remember.
And the back room went and I was trying to find the stairs and I've asked the
lady,
where do I go?
And she goes,
oh,
stand on that thing.
It's like,
no way.
And she goes,
Oh yes.
I was like,
fuck yes.
And then,
um,
I remember coming up through the floor and then all of a sudden there's 40,000
people right in front of you.
And it's like,
wow,
he's amazing.
And then we had a TV audience of 20 million people in Tokyo also.
So it would be a delayed broadcast by about an hour.
I said,
by the time we finish our flight and then on the bus we'll have a TV on the bus
and pretty much what you'll find as your way back to the hotel.
Wow.
But Thailand was pretty cool to Thailand.
We have crowds.
I'm song shy who was fighting for,
he'd have 'em,
he'd make all these money from the TV production.
So he do live shows in the middle of nowhere.
And people would drive for hours to be present to for a live event and we'd have
40,000,
60,000.
Um,
there's this one big event once a year called the king's birthday and we get
100,000 people plus every year and the 5th of December.
Oh,
I was lucky to fight on then a four years in a row.
So the first time I went on the ring,
it was the first time that I,
my knees went weak because as far as I could see was the ocean a heads and I
started trembling and then I've come out in the first round,
I've tried this,
I've tried to finish him,
and then by the fifth round I sort of spent my pennies.
It fell over a couple of times and then I'm losing them points.
And then the next year I got invited back and I sit on,
I'm not going to get spooked yet at this time,
this time,
like,
like the UFC,
Judas,
like you talk about it all the time.
I had the is the first and the second time I was like,
no,
I'm not going to,
I'm going to just tell them I'm going to love it and I'm going to absorb it.
I'm going to run with it.
So I've got it there.
Big Breath in 100,000 people.
And then,
um,
I had the greatest fight of my life.
There was 10 western is verse 10 toys.
And I was the only Westerner to win getting high fives from ties on the way back
to the change room.
And then the last time I did it,
um,
there was probably only 95,000 people had a little tiny kid and I was looking at
the Beck on,
ah,
Geez,
what's going?
Where is everyone?
This is,
this is,
this is sad.
Yeah,
it was nuts.
But you know,
you could tell the difference between 95,000 and a hundred thousand.
Uh,
there was,
there was a little spot near the hot dog stand where you could have been
another,
the 5,000 people easy.
What is that?
Like 100,000 people?
Sometimes a,
you'd have to get a police escort.
So you'd have three policemen either Saudia and they'd push people out of the
way for you as you make your way towards the crowd just to get through it.
And you're the West Center.
So imagine you're the one off three or four westerners that are on the show and
you're just surrounded by Thai people.
That and that,
that stage,
I couldn't really speak Thai very well either.
And um,
they just look at,
you know,
like some sort of freak that you're dead,
you're dead,
you're fighting one of us,
and then you go,
then you go on beat one of them and then all of a sudden they're high five and
year and checking your hand and one photo with you.
And it's just really amazing soul.
You didn't experience as much racism over there.
If you go out there and fight as hard as you can,
win,
lose or draw,
even if you,
if you lose,
but you fight like a,
uh,
like you're a man possessed.
Um,
they love you.
They,
there's no,
there's no hatred.
There's no longer,
as long as you show heart,
it's all about heart and Thailand.
Uh,
true with a lot of Asian countries,
right?
That's the same as Japan,
the Samurai spirit.
If you go out there and give it your all and you go out in a stretcher that they
prefer,
you go out in a stretcher,
then you lay down and borrow from a knees.
Oh,
it hurts.
But that's one of the,
one of the major complaints from a lot of fighters,
like rampage said that many times about,
ah,
the different stream fighting in Japan and fighting in America as an in Japan,
they appreciate effort.
They want you to fight your best.
And if you fight your best,
sometimes you fight someone who's better than you and you lose.
And that's just the way of fighting.
And it's a way of learning.
And that's how guys get better at that,
that adversity from loss and going back and regrouping and watching films and,
and realizing where you have to step your game up.
That's what creates champions.
I mean,
that is what creates a real champion is you have to be able to fight people who
are better than you are as good as you,
or it's,
it's gotta be a really high level that you're aspiring to.
And along the way,
sometimes you lose.
But in Japan,
they treat the losers in those like really high level fights,
words,
just incredible action heart.
And does they treat the losers the same way they treat the winners?
That doesn't happen
in America.
In America.
That's the number one complaint is that people look at you like,
Oh,
you're a loser.
You lost you loser.
I find,
um,
well my toy and in MMA we'll UFC especially,
the crowd I think is a lot better than boxing.
If you have one loss in boxing,
you're done.
You can have it.
You can be 26 and I,
24 knockouts,
one loss are,
he's has been his issue,
retire,
he's done.
And then,
uh,
you have,
if you have two losses in boxing od you then talk about it anymore.
You're out of the,
and especially Kale losses,
Carlos's,
but in a MMA or in a motel,
I especially,
um,
if long as you fight hard and you lose to a guy,
a good guy and your crowd,
p Bass is still going to be there next time around,
you're not going to lose anybody long as you fight hard and if you get knocked
out going out in your shield,
they're still going to be a next time.
There's still support.
Yeah.
Well,
there's a few fighters.
It's still have that kind of support just because they're so excited and like
Vandelay Silva is a perfect example.
Like vandelays been knocked out quite a few times,
but he still has a gigantic following because there's not,
there's no such thing as a boring Vandelay Silva fight every Vandelay Silva
fight.
It's like,
ready,
ready?
Chaos.
Yes.
You know,
are you ready?
Are you ready?
Are you fucking mad violence until that guy's last heartbeat.
You mean every time he fights he fights like a man possessed,
which is why he has so many people that love him.
But a lot of guys,
they felt like,
like Quentin rampage especially,
I hate to keep bringing him up,
but he experienced a lot of hate after,
you know,
after beating chocolate del,
and,
and he was like,
I can't believe people were upset at me for being good,
you know,
cause I beat their hero.
You'd hear all these people would say horrible shit to them.
And I think in that sense the United States crowds,
like there's,
there's something to be desired about some of the people that are excited about
fighting MMA crowd.
I noticed with,
with George,
especially hanging with George and he,
when we were trying to get,
they put a few photos up and then I was more,
I go at each page and always astonished by the amount of hate that George has on
his page.
He has like 4 million people that follow him and he's Twitter and then all it is
when you're going to finish it Vij George or if I need to get asleep,
I just put a judge named Pierre fight or not was a puffer is through the first
round.
And it's like,
fuck man.
He says,
this is one of the greatest fighters of all time.
How can you not appreciate him dominating some of the Veyron?
What is,
you have to know cat someone every single time he fought.
It's fully doesn't look at everybody and he's the highest paid athlete in the
world.
Why can't the same be for MMA guys?
Why if someone dominate someone black,
can you appreciate his skills instead of,
oh,
it has to be an okay.
It has to be in Nakia.
Oh,
believe me.
If you go and watch Floyd and see him interact with the public,
that guy gets fucked with as much as anybody.
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
They showed it on his,
uh,
the 24,
seven,
like one of his last,
uh,
those HBO things for 24,
seven.
Like when he was out at a burger place,
people were heckling them.
Oh,
you're heckling him at a cheeseburger place because the camera's on in,
in his,
in front of us because he's a little guy and it's like it right in front of his
face.
They were fucking with him.
Didn't he get punched by Toa somewhat supposedly punched him.
You know,
I have a hard time believing
some stupid fucking rappers.
Gonna Punch Floyd Mayweather,
you know?
And if he did,
he knew that other people were there,
you know,
put those.
Yeah.
Okay.
You want to hit him?
How about we do this?
How about we lock the two of you in a conference room?
It just,
let's just shut the door and see what the fuck's going on without your buddies
in the room getting punched by a rat match and the dignity thing.
One of the greatest,
if not the greatest boxer of all time.
A lot of people give that Guy Shit and say he's not the greatest it.
Sugar Ray Robinson is a greatest,
like I had this conversation with Max Kellerman about,
about it.
I respect Max Kellerman very much,
but I don't think that,
I don't think that Floyd Mayweather would've lost the Jake lamata would've been
Hula Chavez,
who's amazing and it's time 9,797 a night before his first list,
but Meldrick Taylor was beaten him until he got tagged.
And I don't think Meldrick Taylor is the same boxer that Floyd Mayweather is.
I think Floyd Mayweather defensively is the best ever.
We've seen him get hit like three times and his whole career,
you know my,
Donna cracked him in the last fight,
buddy.
He only cracked him in like at the end of the round.
And you could see like he got rocked in that fight.
He got rocked by Shane Mosley,
but he's just,
he's so good defensively.
So good.
Yup.
That he just never really experienced as much danger in his fights,
you know?
I mean,
you go back to all the other greats and they were in wars.
He's never in a war.
Yeah.
She says never in a war.
And you could talk all the shit you want,
but look at the guys he's fighting.
You know,
he's fighting Juan Manwell Marquez.
Look what happened with [inaudible] Marquez and Pacquiao.
Yeah.
I mean,
they're in a war and mark has caught them and knock them out dead.
You know,
full full was good luck trying to catch Floyd like that.
Good luck.
Yup.
He's just never going to make those kinds of mistakes.
And one of the things that's so exciting about Pacquiao is that he throws
himself into danger.
He puts him in be so aggressive and he's so fast and he's willing to,
he tries to finish fights.
He tries to put himself in the line of fire in order to achieve victory flowing
doesn't do that.
Should Floyd shoulder roll in and,
and,
and popping you at jabs and moving on you and you just get,
you see guys like Canelo Alvarez just look so flustered.
Like they don't know what to do with them.
Yeah.
Let him go.
He's,
they're giving up halfway through the third round.
First round,
the first round they're like,
oh,
I'm going to make a statement today,
which this no one's going to be able to do what I'm going to do.
And then by the third round they just come out like beginners and then they're
too afraid the fray,
because Joe Floyd's already a step ahead of him.
If he had strong hands,
if his hands didn't break all the time.
You know,
like Floyd,
he's had quite a few like broken hands.
He's a serious problem with the handbrakes.
If he didn't have that man,
God damn you know,
if he had punching power as well,
is that insane defensive technique?
Yep.
He's,
in my opinion,
he's the most masterful of all the boxers I've ever watched.
Bernard Hopkins right up there on rewards is another one.
He doesn't get enough credit.
It was like a lot of Americans or for whatever reason,
are not aware of how good Andre Ward is,
but God damn,
he's a good boxer.
Another one just brilliant defensively.
Very rarely see him in trouble.
And he's so different too because Andre Ward fights different styles for
different fighters.
Like some fighters,
he'll fight on the outside,
he'll fight long range and he'll fight.
He'll,
he'll box them.
And then on other other fighters,
he just fucking gets right up in your grill and he's throwing these combinations
and cutting angles on you and never let you breathe.
He's very versatile.
Very smart too,
man.
Yeah.
I missed the nineties I missed the books in the 90s the Oscar de la Hoya is the
Shane Mosley's.
They back in them days are men for men.
It was,
it was fun.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
They do it now.
I don't want to fight you because you might beat me.
Oh zero that might disappear if you beat me.
So I didn't want that happening.
Do you think of guy like Floyd man with her,
cause he's 47 to know that it contributes to that because he makes so much
fucking money.
Him being 47 and Amin that guy,
the money team and rolls around and Rolls Royce that drive you crazy because
you'd taken,
yeah.
Why hasn't taken it so long for Mr [inaudible] get this flight to be done in
these five five five year old fight?
They should have been done ages ago.
Well probably because Floyd is smart,
which is why he's 47 now and he wants to fight him when he knows he beat him and
a tree and $120 million.
I mean that's what's up.
I mean,
what's up at the end of the day?
Look,
if they fought in their primes,
and I'm not saying pack out,
let's be real about this.
Let's be totally real about this pack.
I'll went up eight weight classes and retained his punching power and there was
always all sorts of allegations of special proteins that came and needle forum,
Mexican supplements if you were,
I don't know what the fuck was going on,
but that's one of the things that Floyd oh ways was saying and a lot of other
fighters who said it to,
I don't know if it's true,
but if it is true and Floyd wasn't doing those same things and they did fight
and Pacbio did have that unnatural advantage,
you know,
a few years ago,
like back when he fought Margarito or you know,
back before mark has knocked him out.
You gotta wonder like maybe it's intelligent to not fight a guy like that at
that time.
If you know something that you and I and the regular people that aren't involved
in the deep,
deep in the boxing world,
maybe smart might be smart.
Just,
you know,
nobody wants to see a guy cheat his way to victory.
That's like,
that's something that drives everyone crazy and just no doubt about it.
There's no doubt in the fact that pat gala works hard.
I mean,
Patios,
I was disciplined.
He's focused,
he's amazing fighter.
I mean,
no doubt about it.
But man,
there's a lot of fucking allegations connected to his camp that Alex Mariza guy
that got it left and uh,
and was,
uh,
who the fuck was he training with?
He was training with one of,
uh,
one of Pascal's opponents.
I forgot which fight it was,
but that guy has gotten a lot of weird shit attached to them.
There's a lot of these guys that have a lot of weird allegations that may or may
not be true,
but if you're smart and you're a guy like Floyd Mayweather,
why not avoid those guys?
And that's something that we were talking about earlier today,
because George,
um,
when he was talking
about when he left the UFC and when he said,
I'm going to take a break and I'm going to relinquish my title,
one of the things that he talked about was the problem with pds.
Yep.
We talked,
he said it,
this is a huge problem in MMA and a lot of people poo pooed and we don't need to
name names.
A lot of people said that,
oh,
he's exaggerating,
but now,
man,
it's now with these more stringent tests that are being performed.
Fucking Anderson Silva pisses hot.
Yes.
I mean everybody like Hector Lombard,
who saw that coming,
who's hot?
I didn't,
I can't believe Hector Lombard.
That doesn't make any sense.
He doesn't look like a guy who was on supplements,
but you know,
it's,
it's a part,
it's a part of the sport.
It's very unfortunate.
Uh,
in Thailand,
uh,
if we wanted a pick me up,
the only thing that we would get from the chemist with his Jenson Jenson,
I'd go down and I get 20 genes and in for 20 days.
And,
uh,
that was l and even then for 20 days and they cut you off after 20 days,
let's not get crazy.
I learned,
I laid a small budget.
I'd have to wait for my next flight to get prize money to buy another 25
minutes.
Flight came.
How much does Jensen costs on their eyes?
20 bottles.
A template.
What does a Bot in American money,
50 cents,
50 cents maybe,
maybe.
Hey box for 20 Ginseng tablets.
I was pool.
I was only making $30 a fight back then.
Jeez,
fuck.
And then I'd have to get 50% of that to the camp too.
So you will make what is the cheapest you've ever made for a $30?
$30 and now it's fighting,
um,
ties with a hundred fights and you had to give how much back?
50%.
So the deal with my camp was,
it was,
um,
I live for free train for free in eight train and leave.
And then every time I fought,
I give 50% to the camp and then say if I made 1000 bucks,
500,
if my 10,000 baht is 5,000 and then I was lucky enough to go to me and bought,
say they don't have to get the camp 500,000 baht.
And that was like,
oh my God,
that's like four lots homes of prize money.
Right?
They're saying a million baht would be how much American money?
Uh,
it was 35,000 Australian.
So I bet $10 a strain.
I tend to those American,
no,
what is a million?
I think uh,
the Australian dollar's been equivalent to a peso.
I don't know what that's about.
35,000.
So a million baht is $35,000.
Probably about 35.
No.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
That was the most he made there.
That's insane.
You wonder why you're angry at Floyd Mayweather.
And then I had to give,
I had to get 50% of the camp to 17,000.
At least you're living for free entry.
But sometimes I wouldn't,
wouldn't fight for ages too.
So I needed the,
and then eating for free and had some way to the roof over my head.
I want to talk to you about your journey because as a young man,
as a teenager,
you chose to move to Thailand.
You didn't know the language and you immerse yourself in Thai culture and became
a tie fighter.
I mean,
not as an incredible adventure for a
young man to take part of in a very rare and brave one that not a lot of people
ever didn't,
none of them.
The people really stick their neck out like that and do something along those
lines.
Um,
the movie keep books that came out of the van dam and it's like,
I want to,
I want to walk in this guy's footsteps.
I want to be this guy.
So I had 13 fights in Australia when I'm an Australian toilets.
Happiest if your total.
And then I had a relationship with a guy called Richard Bell who was an orange,
a Thai restaurant,
and he said,
you fought amazing tonight.
Uh,
I want,
I want to know,
do you want to go to Thailand and learn from the best?
I said,
I'd love to lymph in the best.
I'd be amazing.
He said,
if you can organize your passport,
I'll do everything else.
I'll do your plane ticket.
I'll find you a cam.
I'll train,
uh oh two when you go to passport.
And then sure enough,
he bought me a plane ticket and he said,
you must promise me you can't come back for six months.
Um,
if you come back before then me and you had done,
done and dusted.
Wow.
So you got to promise me you're stays.
Okay.
I stay in.
So I went to the,
I went to Thailand,
um,
moved to Bangkok.
I know could speak English.
I had the one of those ones where there's a hole in the ground and you had to
pull in the,
uh,
in the little sheet on the,
and then there's no toilet paper.
I say the poor water in your hand to wipe your bum.
Uh,
yeah.
You had no hot water.
So we had the rinse on,
soap up and then rinse off.
It's hilarious that that is what you would complain about when people are
kicking you in the foot,
legs,
body and head all day.
You got to wipe your ass weird.
And then,
and then sleep,
sleep on a wooden floor and it's 10 other dudes.
And then there's no,
you're from their beds and then,
and that's not including the 70 hours of training and Thai boxing too.
So when you're finished your year,
three and a half hours and at night you got a wooden Florida look forward to,
to go to bed on.
Wow.
No cushion at all.
I put a,
uh,
like a big blanket down as a,
like a bit of cushion in between that and the,
the wood,
how much snoring was involved.
The worst one was the arms and legs.
The ties would throw an arm over here in the middle of the night and you have
this one and get it off in case it took advantage of you.
And then,
um,
yeah,
so I had firefights four,
five wins,
four knockouts came back to Australia and then the Thai can't reign my sponsor.
And I said,
hey,
he looks like he's got a bit of promise.
Can you send him back again?
So my,
he rang me up and said,
you want to go back to the toilet?
And I said,
I'd love to get back to the time that I didn't want to work.
I want to live this type books in dream.
So I said,
okay,
this time you got to promise me 12 months,
don't come back within 12 months.
You've got to commit your whole life.
So sure.
So I went over and then,
uh,
I was fighting them,
the little shows back then,
and then the opportunity to the main guy that was at our camp Sanken he was
falling on a big show.
And then,
uh,
I went to support him.
And then a guy called Danny bill from France,
he was supposed to fight one of the big tires and he didn't,
he never rocked up.
And he did the,
he disappeared something.
And I said,
oh,
I wouldn't get any bills right here.
Who's going to fight this guy?
Am My trying to put his hand up and said,
this guy will,
you're fighting.
And I've absolutely poop my pants.
I shit myself.
And uh,
how many fights did you have at this point?
Uh,
13,
14,
uh,
about 16.
And he said he'll fight him.
He'll,
these guys had like 250 fights.
And Mike,
my young teenager here fired him.
And then,
uh,
he said he can't fight him.
Him fight though.
And does anyone in the room when I fight the white guy and I kid you not about
60 hands went up in the room and I said,
well off fighting,
more fighting.
And so they said,
are you two?
You're the close.
So I ended up fighting this guy in front of,
um,
40,000 people and got cut in the fifth bloodstream and in my face and that I'm
doing half the,
beat him every round.
And then I'm the number one promoter and Thailand,
Thailand said,
okay,
done from near one,
you're going to start fighting for me.
And then I nixed me and I'm sad and find a 60,000,
um,
side of the final and Pini Stadium.
I'm fighting on TV or all the fights I make and the first western.
And to make the,
the number one selling my time magazine in Thailand.
I'm sat in there,
all the toys that are calling me,
the dangerous kangaroo.
And then the air then started reaching the a class guys,
which was a bit,
a bit of a shock,
uh,
afforded.
I called Orono and I'd had 20 fights and he had like close to 300,
and he was like the household name.
He was the Anderson Silva,
almost [inaudible] in Thailand.
And then a third round,
he cut me 21 stitches,
the flight gets stopped.
Um,
so I went down a few pegs and then from then on and backwards and forwards,
backwards and forwards.
And then,
uh,
the year 2000,
I got to,
to rematch the Orono again.
And this time was on the king's birthday in front of 100,000 people live on TV.
And then I scored him,
uh,
every round and when he's walled,
huddle in front of a,
all these ties.
And then from that moment on,
all of a sudden I started becoming a sort of a celebrity and toilet,
not a celebrity,
but in the Moitai Ward.
I was somebody near.
Wow.
That's amazing.
And then from there I come back to Australia,
opened the gym and then uh,
I had no trainer and then so all I've got a few of my friends even to this day I
get my friends,
Hey,
can you hold the pedal like this?
I watched the fight that the provider ring.
Hey,
do you want to fight this guy?
Okay.
So I'll tell my friend,
hey,
can you hold the pads like this?
And then um,
then I'll go and fight.
Hey,
do you want to come to give me some water in between rounds?
So when you were training in Australia self-trained self train to the Sam's to
self trained to this day.
Yeah.
But your,
your time in Thai,
in Thailand you are training with the best just so the toys,
they said okay,
you pretty much have to been here for five years.
You pretty much Noel system now all you have to do is get fit and then I'll come
back to Australia and so I've been doing and just help them get my friends to
help me.
Do you feel like there's anything that you miss when you do that as opposed to
like training in Thailand?
Like with those guys?
Like if you had your druthers,
like if you had a choice,
would you have like a worldclass tar trainer come and train with you in
Australia?
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
But at the same time it's been working.
What I've been doing is working,
I've,
I've of being quite good assist for the last 15 years,
but doing it by myself and it's like middleman.
Eva,
how don't have to worry about a manager or someone telling me what to do.
And I'm s um,
I pushed myself in my training to a high standard where,
um,
uh,
I guess doing okay cause I won another eight world titles doing it by myself
against it now after I've been lucky enough to travel the world too.
I'm gone all over Europe
and you're fighting in Japan 16 times and um,
yeah,
beaten everybody in Australia already set for my last one but um,
ba and that's been good.
I like it.
You fought some legends to man.
I mean your,
your,
your record.
If you look at all the,
the names like the legends of [inaudible],
you fought quite a few of them man.
Yeah,
it's been cool.
I have the,
Oh and um,
like you were saying before to,
to,
to be that there would get famous,
you've got to fight the famous guys.
I don't want to be one of these ones are like,
uh,
I'm not afraid to step up and if I lose to him,
at least I had a car I tried.
But majority of Tom I'm winning.
It's like,
yeah,
I can't believe I beat that guy.
I shit myself for the last six weeks getting ready for you and I have one.
So how good's this is awesome.
Say Yeah.
And then sometimes I'll match myself as well with someone.
Like,
it's like the crowd is going on,
why are you fighting this guy?
You like your old,
this guy is going to wipe the four and then I win again.
It's like,
it's just a such as self satisfying feeling to know that um,
I can still compete with the elite.
Do people give you a hard time because you're old?
Because when you're not that old,
you're younger than me.
38 but 38 in combat sports is,
yeah,
it's definitely,
but I've been getting told off.
I've been always since I was 27,
28 even though I was in the k one that was,
I was the old guy then being 28 years old,
28 years old and Yay.
Yay going.
Well,
when are you going to give it up?
And then
it's one of those ones.
I want to ride it to the last wave until once you did.
You did.
And I don't want to regret not doing what I'm doing and just hold in peds.
I'd rather be in the limelight and still trying to reach that pinnacle there
than the Mount Everest of fighting.
So how many more years do you think you can do it at 38 years old?
Do you have a number in your head or do you just do it while your body is
healthy and why you enjoy?
Why I just want to keep going.
Um,
uh,
been a Hopkins is 50.
He was supposed to retire when he was 40.
He promised his mom and he was going to give it up when he's 40 and he's lasted
another 10 years and he's still fighting the elite and still winning world
titles and his mom die.
Yeah.
Some guys like that,
you know?
Well,
I promised them
even here anymore.
I don't know.
He's,
he's so good defensively.
You know,
he's another one.
He's a killer.
He's,
he's a great bio.
It was amazing.
He was willing to fight Calvillo at this stage of his life at 49 years,
eight of age fights.
One of the best knockout artists like in the last decade in that division.
Yeah.
It's a crazy,
it's I'm skills.
Yeah.
It's just skills.
Having skills,
you know,
having the ability to know what to do in any given time.
Step.
Nowhere step.
No,
no.
What's coming,
you know,
and like we were saying no,
that language,
he knows the language of boxing so well.
And you don't get famous holding peds.
He didn't get famous writing.
Cool Facebook posts.
I try,
but it doesn't happen.
That's repeating that you've repeated that many times.
Like they're getting famous.
Yeah.
Getting famous.
That's a,
that's a big part of what,
what motivates you right.
Since was about
five or six years old.
Um,
every time I look into the sky and see a single star and I wish I can be
remembered,
uh,
when I blow my birthday candles out,
I wish that I can my legacy.
Once I die,
I can be that guy that people go,
Yup.
My Empire.
Wow.
That's interesting man.
That's um,
that's a weird drive for a young man to have.
What do you,
what do you attribute that to?
Like to want to want to be remembered?
Yeah.
Muscle.
My whole life.
That's my only goal.
Winning a world title was always,
I didn't want to win a world title.
I wanted to win a world title and Tyleen against the tie against a genuine,
I don't want to win against someone down the road.
I always wanted the take it to that next level.
And then once I did win the world title and that went into and Bangkok,
but now it's about the legacy news about the,
the,
yeah,
like any human being.
Once you pass your yes,
turn into flowers.
And I want to be,
I wanted people like Dick,
like the remainder respected.
I show him after he's passed away for the last couple of years,
I want people to look with me in exactly the same light.
Hopefully one day he died of a heart attack while riding a bike.
Right?
Yeah.
In the park by himself.
No,
we would know when to give him any CPI.
Just pass away.
That's so crazy.
Do they know what was wrong with them?
I mean it doesn't even make sense.
Yeah.
Who knows.
I'm 42 years old and then I'm going to push mark is crazy.
You were talking to me earlier about the injuries that he had suffered,
that he,
he had his foot fused to his ankle.
Yes.
He's broken.
He's like that many times.
This is what I've seen from the documentary.
I could be wrong.
Um,
I'm sure Beth would have a better understanding of being Dutch.
But um,
yeah.
From,
from the,
the stories that he told me,
his leg was,
uh,
going to amputate it.
It was got to the stage where he said,
well,
what else can we do?
Oh,
we can fuse your ankle to your Shin.
So he used to say,
I used to just do peds.
I wouldn't spa and just save it to the fight.
And then if it broke,
it broke.
But I just changed the Southport and then hopefully not use it.
And,
but then he was so adamant that I had the,
when he just go back to Orthodox and just start using it anyway,
it's just that crazy mentality because it kept breaking it.
If he kept breaking it,
they were going to have to amputate it.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's what the documentary said anyway.
He's still kicking it.
Yeah.
So nuts.
I remember when he fought and Duane Ludwig and the,
his last fight,
and Kaitlin,
uh,
we're,
we call an elevator together and I said,
hey,
you're feeling we has it all go and you feel good.
And he showed me his arm and his arm was black from his wrist to his shoulder.
And he said,
I've pulled my bicep.
I can't punch.
Right.
It's okay.
I win.
No problem.
And sure enough he dropped the Duane Ludwig three or four times.
I don't know if it was 1.2 by knockout,
but he won by points.
But the points we want to,
yeah,
that's incredible.
And that's just,
that's him.
That's,
and then you see something like that and you think,
ah,
I want to be that guy.
It's,
I'm so torn on that because on one hand I admire mental toughness.
I mean obviously,
I mean that's just the ability to block that
out and say it's okay,
I'll wing no problem.
I mean that's incredible.
But in the other hand,
he's an example of what happens when you are really mentally tough as is.
His legs were shot,
his ankles were fucked up,
his body was falling apart.
It's like you red line your body.
Cause that's how he fought.
He fought red line.
I mean,
if you've never seen Ramon Dekkers fight,
if you,
someone who is,
uh,
you're,
you're not aware of Moy Tai,
just to yourself a favor and Google Ramon decker,
I mean a lot.
There's a lot of people that folks will talk up and you know,
you watch it and it's like,
well they kind of exaggerate it.
You can't do that guy justice.
You can't do him justice.
He got to watch how violently he fought.
Just it was so hyper aggressive and vicious knockout power,
beautiful combinations and everything he threw was 100%.
Everything he threw,
there was no set ups.
Everything was fine.
It was just so exciting to watch man and but look,
his body just eventually just deteriorated and fell apart.
And the ways where is the line lane ways he did it at the legacy show pass the
longevity.
Say he'll never be forgotten.
Full hell tenacious and how crazy and how violent he was.
So that's what I want.
I want to go until I can't go anymore.
And then if I pass,
I wanted to be a member for that.
Glad that it seems interesting that it's as Saundra.
Maybe only the only way to be great is to kind of like break your body trying to
be great.
It seems like,
like look at Cain Velasquez.
He can't get through a training camp.
I mean he's,
he's fought two times I think in the last few years and it's because everything
keeps breaking.
His knee keeps fucking up,
his shoulders keep fucking up and it's because he's so mentally tough is because
any injury that,
that guy has just goes in the back of his brain and it's just,
Paul is a champion.
It's just juggernaut press forward,
you know,
attack,
attack.
And these guys that have that ability to ignore Chris Weidman is another one.
He just keeps him injuring himself.
He's had knee surgery,
he just fucked up his ribs.
How many crews get Dominick Cruz?
Another one.
It's like they're there.
This is,
this drive to attack and succeed oftentimes forces their body to just like the
body says,
listen dude,
you're at,
you're being crazy here.
You can't keep doing this.
We're just going to check out.
How about we give you a little knee injury here and take,
take six months off.
You know,
it's like the adrenaline drug getting in front of that crowd.
Of the,
the 5,000,
10,000,
20,000.
You can buy it.
I've tried.
He just came like,
but anyway.
Do you worry about like being in it past your prime or do you think that you'll
know when it's time to stop?
Uh,
I retired three years ago digit and then I thought,
I thought I'll go in and talk.
I've had,
I was on a five or six fight winning streak,
um,
at,
but then in six months it was driving me just that,
not
being that the famous guy anymore.
We've not been in the magazines,
not being on TV,
not people coming up and not giving that recognition anymore.
And then I came back and I went on another fire fight winning streak and I,
it was so good to be back amongst the minx and to,
to the,
the being in front of that crowd again.
Um,
I understand why people can't give it up and they keep coming back out of
retirement because it is the most exciting thing that you could possibly do on
earth is the stand in front of someone and try and knock each other out when
you're done.
Do you think that you will become a trainer?
I mean do,
you can have it.
I've got my gym for the last 15 years and then I've been lucky enough to tour
the world doing seminars and teaching,
which I get a kick out of,
but yeah,
it's not fighting.
It's not,
it's not.
It's not punching on.
Do you ever think you would run a gym in Thailand?
No.
That'd be a disrespect to the ties.
The ties are so good and to have a western,
that could be a disrespect,
I believe.
Sorry.
Even calling myself crew,
I cringe when people call me a crew.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Because I'm not a tie and I don't deserve the honor of being called a crew.
I'm them.
I'm,
I'm a a white guy trying to be the best possible version of a type person.
That's very interesting because Americans used that that term all the time.
Like crew Mark Della [inaudible] is a good example is my friend Mark Telegraph.
And then so many people that I've met,
I don't respect and I someone call someone,
a crude Oklahoma crew crew,
mark or crew are going to cover my tais.
Shut up.
Now
Rhino,
what does crew Rhino mean?
Take courage teacher.
I know what that means,
but why is it so crew,
Roz is my fight name.
Oh,
how dare you lecture.
Just put my jacket on that
Eh,
but um,
so the,
the term crew is like a deep,
deep respect.
Um,
I've spent five years here.
I've,
I've been a monk of,
I've done my whole business of you've been a monk?
Yeah,
I was a monk for seven days.
I went to twice a long time.
Lived in,
lived in,
um,
every,
every time.
It all has to be a monk once in their life.
So even if it's,
if it's seven days,
you're still a monk.
Really?
Every tie.
What?
Every time mail has to be a more time male.
Yes.
You have to be a monk for,
for how long can get open seven days a month,
three months,
six months,
one year,
two years.
But whatever you commit to,
you must stay there for that amount of time.
You kind of um,
giving.
So you were a monk for seven days?
Yes,
I had all my possessions taken away and I had my head shaved,
the library shaved.
I lived in the title tag.
Brow shaved.
Yeah.
They shape your eyebrows too.
Why are they shave your eyebrows to make you look like among
the parts of the body.
So say you have this,
you have this bowl and then every morning you walk this track and then there's
two people on the side of the road given your offerings.
So they give you rice,
they give you meat,
they give you this to give you that.
And then you say chance to them.
And that's helped to give them good Karma for either that day or that week or
maybe in a future life.
And then every morning we had a blind,
a blind lady and her sister would come and hold a hand,
put the spoon into a bowl,
would say this chant.
And um,
it just was so special that everyday we said this thing to her to help her have
this good energy because life must be shitting,
not being able to see.
So,
and it just meant so much to us,
really for us come room.
And then,
um,
everyday we had Buddhist studies and then they were saying how the Buddhist is
the most oldest religion out of everything.
Uh,
it was 500 years older than Christianity,
which is a,
a few hundred years,
uh,
older again than a Muslim.
Uh,
so,
and,
and then they took everything.
There's five main things with,
uh,
Buddhism.
The don't kill,
don't steal,
don't cheat,
don't do drugs,
uh,
and don't lie.
And then the Christianity took those and the edit a few things to them as well.
But the best thing about Buddhism,
the,
there's no supernatural guy.
It's just an old prints that was stuck in a kingdom.
And then he didn't see the real outside world.
NC poor people didn't see sickness.
And then one day he went out of the Kingdom and uh,
he realized that his whole life was a lie.
So he went out into the forest and started doing,
um,
meditation.
And that's when all these different things coming from different aspects of,
so,
and then from those,
from,
uh,
the meditation,
that's when he made these five basic principles.
If you,
if you don't drink,
you're not going to tell lies and you're not gonna get in trouble and you're not
going to kill anybody.
So have you stay away from those things you'll,
you should be.
Love.
Should be.
Okay.
That's hilarious.
So incorrect.
A lot of people that don't drink,
they're full of shit.
Yeah.
And if you,
if you don't,
if you don't screw your neighbor or you don't,
um,
steel and nothing,
you don't have to.
Yeah.
So all these bases,
just easy stuff.
Just the idea of doing good behavior and being a good person and keeping a Karma
coins.
Yeah,
for sure.
So did you have a desire to do it for longer than seven days or did you do it
just because he lived in Thailand and you did it out of respect or my tie
sponsor,
his two boys were doing it and they said they're going on for seven days.
Do you want to join them?
He said you've done everything.
Tie,
you speak Thai,
you live like a tie.
You fight like a tie.
The only thing you haven't done has been a month.
And then once you have them the monkey,
you're the complete circle.
You're the white version of one of them.
So yeah.
Yeah,
it was,
it was amazing.
It was so cool.
So when you went there,
they,
you'd shave your eyebrows,
you shave your head,
they'll give you a bowl and then what do you do during the day?
What does the day after we get the,
we have breakfast in the morning.
We do Buddhist studies for about an hour or two hours after that.
Um,
and then we're either sweeping around the temple,
keeping everything clean,
and then afternoon will be Buddhist studies again in front of the error half and
two hours.
And then we sleep in the temple and try not to get attacked by ghost.
Yeah,
the ghost was scary cause yeah.
Thailand,
this ghost of so full on,
uh,
the,
they really had this thing where they really believe in him.
So the tire,
the ghosts have a more of a tendency as shown themselves or come into your dream
form and then it's so realistic.
They,
it was life changing.
I had a few different dreams where I came into the temple thinking,
fuck,
I'm changing the way that I do things from here on in.
Why is that just,
I'm just making me a better person for,
for just basic things.
The ghosts.
We're making you a better person.
Yeah.
They,
they just give you deep inner thoughts.
Why,
why you're dreaming and you wake up.
You'd think that you'd was real life,
but it was,
uh,
yeah.
It's hard to explain.
No,
please do.
So you,
you saw ghost as well.
I used to get attacked about three or four times a week.
Um,
they call it a PM.
Uh,
so it,
have you ever heard of sleep paralysis?
So in Thailand they believe it's a go sitting on your chest.
And then if the ghost doesn't like you,
the ghost puts his hand across your mouth and nose and suffocate you in your
dream,
in your,
in your sleep and as well.
Yeah.
And you're doing asleep.
They're wrong though too.
You know that.
So,
so,
so when I told the the tires,
I had this crazy dream last night,
I was,
I felt like I was getting held to the floor.
I couldn't move.
And they said,
oh,
that's just a PM.
So I wasn't mean.
I was just to go sitting on your chest.
Oh no worries.
Me Feel better.
Try to kill it so crazy that they would be like,
no worries.
And then you'll say,
I'm sleeping right beside someone.
And then the case would sit on your chest.
You want to scream,
you want to reach your hand out.
So someone woke you up,
but you're just stuck and there's nothing you can do.
And the,
how do you try and screen the more that you just get stuck to the floor.
So this would happen on a consistent basis,
four or five times a week.
How old were you at the Dome?
19.
19 to 23.
So if I had a gas,
you're,
you're a young man,
you're in Thailand for the first time.
You're experiencing this incredible culture shock.
You're also experiencing the anxiety of preparing for fights.
There's whole new world that you're living in and you probably have a lot of
questions and doubts about life and you know,
[inaudible] there's anxiety,
a lot of built up stuff.
And then you're hanging around a bunch of people that are telling you to ghost,
to trying to kill you.
Yeah.
And so you're experiencing these,
these ghosts to regularly now,
did you see anything?
Did you physically see something,
would you say?
Um,
one night I was laying in bed and,
and uh,
one of those ones where the eyes were closed as been about five minutes.
And,
uh,
I heard that,
there was only me in the room at the time too.
So I heard the door,
the fly screen open and I'm thinking,
and I heard footsteps and they immediately think ghost.
Now I'm thinking heart and close the door before the mosquitoes coming and then
waiting,
waiting.
No one's going to close the door.
I roll over.
It might.
And as this person standing at the door and then he looks at me and then he
turns and I hear him walking down the steps from Compton.
Dumb mother fucker.
He didn't close the door.
Mosquitoes.
So I get up,
I don't know,
I'm awake.
I get up,
I closed the door to go back to sleep.
I'll get like close my eyes with another couple of minutes.
The door,
the door opens again.
Bang.
No one's closing the door.
Knife,
footsteps.
Just time.
I look at it,
there's a cat sitting at the door and it jumps up on the shelf.
Then jumps out the window.
I think a fuck.
So this is the second time I get up,
I close the door
and I'll go back.
This time I gave back the seat and the next morning and I go and see the,
the tie train.
I think,
I swear your brother was here last night and he,
um,
he must have come to the room,
but he couldn't.
I know he left the door open and got up and he said,
no,
he's not.
He in Changwale he's about 12 hour driveway.
So now,
no,
I seen him.
He was here 100%.
So now watch or ring is,
hey brother,
wait,
wait.
And he said,
I'm Chingway.
It's like,
Oh shit.
So yeah,
so that was,
yeah,
that was my scene.
The ghost,
uh,
firsthand,
the ghost of a dude who's alive and was 12 hours away.
Sorry.
It's really common in Thailand.
Like it's,
this is not about me,
it's all about John.
But it happened to me a lot as well.
And I think it's because we're around the ties as well.
So the suggestion,
that power of suggestion,
the culture,
do you know about the goatee houses?
Ghost houses.
Every Thai house has a ghost house.
I say your house looks this noise and they have a little house in front of their
house and they decorate it more so it's more attractive for the ghost.
This is true story and then they put food,
little bits of rice a little bit to drink and then a little bits of whiskey
sometimes and then before your fight you pray to the Ghost House that they,
the ghosts will hopefully give you a good inner strength for when you go into
battle.
Well,
it's easy to ridicule.
It's easy to ridicule and make fun of.
But I think that when you look at things like the power of suggestion and the
placebo effect,
what that means,
what it really means is that the mind has incredible capabilities.
The mind has the ability to heal you if you're sick.
The mine has the ability to do all sorts of things that you think you need a
drug or medication to fix.
I mean that's the mine is amazing and if you are around a bunch of people that
really believe these things,
your mind is almost preparing you for these things.
Being real.
I don't know if ghosts are real or not real.
I've never experienced it,
but everyone I know that has like studied it.
There's two types of people.
These either and maybe I haven't met enough of them,
but they're charlatans who like,
you know,
they,
they're just the guys who do those shows where there got like night vision there
in a basement somewhere and like,
did you hear that when we cut to commercial?
You know,
I'll never see her shit.
Like those ghost hunting shows like you want to talk about a show like a genre
with the least amount of success.
It's like it might be ghost hunting shows.
Those motherfuckers have never seen a ghost.
Like there's never a gut like you see it,
you go,
oh shit,
that's a ghost.
I got held down in Australia once held down,
say say my Thai training came and then I hadn't met frustrating for a couple
months.
Say he's saying he's like,
what?
He's Buddhist in his hand,
his hand,
his big pray before I'm asleep.
I said,
be,
why are these night,
we're not an in Thailand now there's negotiate west suite.
So you've got held down by ty goes and say,
I've gone into my room.
And then as one of those scenarios again where,
uh,
I'm just stripped,
drifting off and I hear the door open,
I'm thinking,
oh,
someone must be come in and get something out of the room.
And then I,
he puts it and then boom,
I'm held down as hard as I can until the mattress and I've got enough energy to
open my eyes.
And uh,
there was nothing there but I heard I could hear the breathing.
And then,
um,
I tried to relax,
I felt the pressure come off my chest and then as soon as they let me go grab my
towel on my blanket and I went and slept in the toys bedroom for two weeks when
these floor,
because I was too petrified asleep by myself for about two weeks.
I think I shifted myself so bad cause I had my eyes,
I could hear it.
So again,
if I had to get,
one of the things that I would say is not only young and the power of suggestion
always things are a factor,
but also the fact that these things are happening to your wife's sleeping.
Yeah.
When you're sleeping,
your mind produces all sorts of crazy psychedelic chemicals.
So it's very possible that what you're experiencing,
some semi dream state.
And then in the semi dream state,
especially if you're convinced that go surreal and your brain starts,
your imagination,
starts flooding your consciousness with all sorts of physical experiences.
He's all sorts of physical sensations or go surreal.
That's possible too.
I mean,
I don't know,
I might be wrong.
It's just,
there's so much fuckery involved.
Ghosts.
You know,
when you,
when you look at the people that are telling you about them and the people that
say that they've seen them,
it's just,
it's so,
it's such a weird subject.
It's a big,
big pot of the tall end though.
I worked for the rescue team like we spoke about last time and it's actually
quite nice hearing.
He said it's tough because I'm like,
oh my God,
I'm not crazy.
Like one of my heroes,
John My pot this too.
But uh,
yeah man,
like everyone I know in Thailand has had something and they are so
superstitious.
It's not even money.
It's ridiculous how superstitious hell they believe.
The ghost living trees.
So when you chop a tree down and then build your house,
the ghost comes with the house that goes,
comes with say.
Then there's certain polls that might be,
might be a bit more crazy than more powerful.
And even the ring,
the ring is made out of wood.
So we used to decorate the ring with ribbons and um,
powder and perfume and then we'd pray to the ring just before a fight because it
helped get us fit for that six weeks,
eight week prep,
and then say,
and then we've decorated with flowers and blood flow is just the day before the
fight to say thank you for my preparation.
Just Blah.
Just a little tighter additions,
more than say,
than anything,
I guess.
Even if it's not true.
Like if I look at,
I'm joking around,
obviously I really don't know of ghosts are real,
but even if they're not real,
there's something to be said for eliminating a certain amount of anxiety just by
having this ritual,
having this process that you go through in your mind where you believe you've
appeased the ghost so you believe that you will have good luck.
So you believe that?
Yeah,
you have good Karma,
that you have good spirits with you.
I mean if you believe in ghosts and you're,
you know,
you're worried about the unknown and you find a ritual that appeases that and
then settles that fear.
I mean there's benefit in that,
it this,
but there's benefit in a lot of crazy beliefs with them.
The Rem way before,
often before a fine.
So you are down there praying and your,
your thinking of the people of the past,
the people in the present,
the different people don't know what you're talking about because we explain it.
The preflight dance that we do in Thailand.
So we should put up a video of that so people could see it as these,
it's pretty fucking cool.
And it doesn't exist in any of their combat sport.
Uh,
at most combat sports.
I mean the,
the most you get is someone walks around and touches each corner of the,
of the ring and maybe bows or puts their hands up.
And in Thailand it said live tie band too.
So they have a gland that drums are going and the symbols are going and the
flute and then a boy,
your boy you're dancing,
you just,
uh,
you might be 100,000 people there and then you just turn it all off and then you
just praying for you.
I'm asking permission from the Earth,
the wind,
the fire,
the water,
um,
food from God a to give you all this inner strength.
And I myself,
I think from my mother and my father and my grandfather and my grandmother's a
past,
present future,
uh,
former trainers.
Um,
every single person that helped you get to that present point in that particular
second that you think thanking for helping.
You get right there in that time.
And then,
um,
you take a big breath in all that energy just fills up your whole body and it
was all you get pins and needles in the hair stands up on the back of your neck
and then once you finish the dance,
it feels like you're a,
you're invincible.
Wow.
When these guys are doing it right now and they have the traditional hand wraps,
they have,
this is a,
there's your,
we're starting to see that come back or you're,
you're seeing a lot of,
uh,
bounce that are being made today with a really hand wraps and no gloves.
Yeah,
it's pretty,
pretty hectic.
They said once a year entirely and for ever.
And they have totally inverse Burma and they have two referees.
And then what happens?
You can only win by knockout or cut if it goes the distance.
It's a draw,
no matter how much someone's winning,
it's,
it's always a drawer.
So you have to win by a violence.
How many rounds?
Uh,
five,
five rounds.
Wow.
And you,
you can't win by any other way by knock out or cut.
That's crazy.
And then there's not many kicks her knees cause you know,
you were in um,
two weapons on your fists.
So it's just a healthy liver technique is a Linda and then more so survival.
Well weapons on your fist,
meaning that it's just the rope because it's not,
those are not like traditional hand wraps where it's like soft and cushiony.
Yeah.
What is that?
It's a,
it's proper and it goes all the way down the forearm to,
why is that?
Cause I like to protect you from Kix.
Uh,
I'm not sure it was traditional,
I think.
Tell me a bit about the bedding with uh,
the Weichert as well.
Yes.
Um,
a lot of,
a lot of toys will,
um,
make judgment on who dances better.
Also in the WHO,
who is more relaxed in,
who has a bit of a rhythm and stall with their,
with their dances.
Well so they can see who was,
um,
if you are stiff and fucked up and we're another go,
I is just flowing like a,
like a ballerina and then go,
oh,
this guy has got this for sure.
And when you're watching this,
like when they're doing this dance,
is it,
there's a specific routine they follow or are they just being like,
they just going with the flow of things?
Some,
some gyms have the their own stall or the majority of the time it's pretty much
the same thing.
But uh,
yeah.
Different.
Why are you praying at this thought?
That's,
that's my biggest thing is getting connected to the universe and uh,
trying to,
trying to get good energy and in the rest of this stuff that they're doing.
Yeah.
It's more so of a limbo.
So you,
as you're going from rope the rope,
you're warming up your body,
you're stretching out the shoulders,
you're stretching at your legs.
And the guy explained to me once also the way he did it,
he would relax because it was,
um,
it was sorta performing in front of all these people.
Yes.
As he was doing it and it helped him perform better in his fighting cause it
wasn't just like,
are you ready?
Are you ready?
Go.
Yes.
Like he'd already done something in front of all these people and then it sort
of loosen up,
loosen them up.
Before I ever did a commentary for the UFC,
I got the comment tight on a one of a cobots fight and luck some toy.
How'd he say it?
I was on,
I believe so.
Yeah.
This was way back in the days before 2002,
which was when I was,
when I started commentating for the u s I started,
I was the post fight interview guy and like 97 to 98 and then I commentated from
2002 on.
But in between then I was working at um,
uh,
not working.
I was working out at a John Jack Machado's and me and Richard Norton,
uh,
you know where she's in Australia and gay.
Yeah.
Martial arts guy.
We show some stuff together.
Yeah.
He,
um,
he and I did a,
we commentated on coal bonds fight.
It was amazing.
It was amazing to see like a real tie legend who said,
who knows how many hundred fights you got to get the to fight to get the Bangkok
Bank cooks amazing.
I don't know,
eventually maybe I'll do a UFC out there,
but is it a UFC even legal there tried to ban it a couple of times and I think
that ties you a little bit funny about the cage because it's taken away from
the,
uh,
they didn't want it to taking over the sport going toy,
like it's taking over every other country in the womb.
It must have been an amazing experience for you.
Just,
I mean,
just to go there as a young man,
as a teenager and just get immersed in this life.
It's so different than just like taking a Moyie Thai class at a gym or even
getting obsessed with Moy Tai in Australia or in America where you know,
you're working out all the time and you love boy tie.
But to be living there,
Thailand,
the best pilot that I look back at one upon is not just the,
the,
the training and the fighting,
but the ghosts becoming a white tie,
white tie.
Because I was the only Westerner for,
I'd go months and months on end without seeing another white person.
Wow.
I was like the freaky,
if you will.
And then I'd go to the shops in,
every single person would stare at me and I love it.
And now I can speak Thai.
So I sat talking to them and they'd freak out and I'd,
and then I'd start going to the nightclubs.
And,
um,
uh,
for instance,
sometimes I'd have a live band and then I'd go up to the band and saying,
Hey,
you know,
this song.
And then I,
I,
they give me the microphone and I'd seen tie through the crowd and
the crowd would bounce that everyone's like dancing.
And stuff.
That's crazy.
It was awesome.
It was such a good buzz to wow.
To live in,
to live,
to live like one of them.
So that sounds insane.
It was awesome.
It was so cool.
Wow.
Must've been to such a,
you're like a whole new universe and you come back to Australia and you had just
blend in with everyone else and then you go back to Thailand and you're back to
being that special person in the suburb again.
And then I used to run on the road and everyone used to flash your lights and me
and toot their horn because I was the fighter kid,
the Ozzie cause he guy.
So I was,
I was special.
It was really amazing to you really enjoyed that aspect of it.
Just being unique,
being unique,
getting in a taxi and talking to her,
the taxi driver and I could just have a conversation forever.
I was going and just talking about everything will be right most I of course.
But um,
wherever I went I was just,
it was so cool in a sense.
Is that place like your second home?
Uh,
I don't get in any more now.
The last time I went there was probably three or four years ago when I fought
yards in glee.
But um,
but yeah,
because now the fights are so hard for such little money.
Like if I went back now,
I'd be lucky to make it $1,000 a fight.
I'm better off fighting Westerners and I can make 10 times the amount of money
for an easier fight,
if that makes sense.
It's just amazing that you're paid that left that low amount to fight in front
of 100,000 people because if I lived there,
the currencies quite quite high.
But then synergy or transfer that over to Australian and then you can't even,
boy and Donald's talk about taxis is actually in a taxi.
Oh God.
About six,
seven years ago,
he goes,
oh,
what are you doing here in time?
And like,
and I'm doing my Tai Chi o you know,
Raymond Deck?
I'm like,
yeah,
no room.
Deca.
He goes,
wait from like Australia goes,
Oh,
you're not John Wayne Park.
Oh Shit.
That's awesome.
That's a long time ago.
How long did it take you to learn the language?
Uh,
three months before I could hold one conversation.
So,
uh,
I remember the very first I used to,
I used to learn,
uh,
okay,
eat kin,
drink a dumb numb,
and then I've got my first sentence.
I still remember it as a,
that they said,
okay,
we're going to send you to the shop.
We want you to say,
um,
I would like one bag of ice upon Dongen numb Kang Known Tom.
So as I walked down the street in my head upon them,
um,
and then,
uh,
from there I work okay if instead of saying ice upon Dungan and cook or upon
long and then a right.
And then I started getting sentences and then I'd start asking questions,
okay,
what's this?
What's that?
What's this?
And then before I knew it,
all of a sudden I was,
um,
I was one of them.
Wow.
I can't read or write,
but I can hold,
I started watching the soap operas on the TV.
I could watch the news.
I started picking up the songs.
Now.
Now the songs had meanings besides just noise,
right?
Uh,
yeah,
that's gotta be bizarre when it sort of starts revealing itself to me.
I started thinking toy was there for that long.
I stopped thinking English and I started thinking in Thai.
Uh,
that's when it got scary because I came back to Australia and I start my
sentences in English and I finished him and tie.
But I wouldn't know that I was finishing his eye looking at me going,
what the hell did you just say?
And then I started to speak in pigeon because the toys,
um,
I started,
uh,
me hungry me,
me,
Firsti don't have to westerners.
And I like,
oh,
what am I doing?
But it was just normal because that's the way I lived for so long while just
trying to figure out how to readjust.
Yeah.
It took a wall to go.
That's so bizarre.
It was cool.
It was,
that's fascinating that you did it without any books now.
And there's no internet.
So if I wanted to talk to mum,
I'd have to write a letter.
It always takes seven days to get to Australia and then she'll reply to be a
seven day returns.
There was a two week,
two week waiting period between no Facebook,
no,
no Google.
No,
no,
no.
I have no idea if you were okay.
If it's every now and again she might ring for my birthday or ring for a special
occasion or if someone passed away,
hey,
bad news.
Such as if the phone rang and it was for me the be the really good news or
really bad.
So did you have any desire to try to learn how to write it or how to read?
I tried,
but there's like a 27 valves and one if you put one letter at the start of a
word,
it's a completely different noise.
If you put an end of a word and it's all tones.
So one word means five things.
So the word cow,
Carmine's rice,
white mountain news knee.
So if you say,
if you say it in a different tone,
I'd like to have a plate of knees.
What's the tone like?
What are the different ways of saying,
ah cow,
cow,
cow.
Wow.
So,
and then,
yeah,
it's all timing and say the whole time you're talking,
it's almost like you're singing.
Wow.
Asian languages are so fascinating to me.
A lot of the words are the same words,
like the word California's sins,
cow or luck.
So you just,
it's the same word.
It's a different meaning.
So I try and I try and learn five words a day.
I go to bed and land,
land on my pillow.
All right,
got it.
Next Day.
Okay,
now five new more things.
Okay.
Doop,
doop,
doop.
And then you can only kind of keep those things in your head if you're,
you're,
you practicing it on a regular basis.
Right.
And because I live with kids as well,
those kids in the camp,
and then you could joke around with them and if you said something wrong,
they'd laugh and go,
no stupid.
It's,
he say it like this,
but he said it to an adult.
You feel a little bit sort of shy and embarrassed by it.
But to a kid you just slap on the back of the head and they said the [inaudible]
laugh anymore.
So,
um,
child beating by John Wayne part.
This is how you learn language properly.
Speaking of Baiting Thailand,
so back there,
there's,
there's still um,
they still beat their boxes.
It's still pretty.
There's no,
no one looks down upon it.
So if the tires,
if they're not training hard,
it's nothing for them to get a slap across the face or are kicking the leg or a
punching them may awful.
Um,
yeah,
they,
they
want their books is to exceed everything else.
So the child cruelties still pretty normal.
So child cruelty meaning that's one thing that maybe people aren't aware of.
They start fighting very young.
Yeah.
So if you fight and you're afraid of your opponent,
they have the thing called around six and then that might include you getting
bashed by one of the trainers after you get home.
And then it's like,
okay,
around six meaning you fight five rounds and then you come back and they come
back and then you get your ass kicked.
And this like what are you going to be scared of if you're going to be scared of
the training,
kicking your ass when you get back.
Are you going to be scared of your opponent,
someone your size and weight with rules or are you going to be scared of me so
they get more scared of the round six and they do their opponents and then they
turn in the beam men very fast.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Is to make kids like walk home.
I've tried to pick up a kid down here from my account a couple of years back and
they're trying to shout him if we're giving a lift home,
I'll go like a lot of trouble with the camp because they he lost and he had no
heart and they've said no,
he's got a walker.
It was like,
it was like a 30 minute drive.
Lebanon,
like a walk view one in the morning.
It's weird because they don't get a chance or like they don't get a choice
rather whereas like if you have a young kid and they really aspire,
there's some young kids that they aspire to fight.
At a very young age and that's what they're driven to.
These kids,
a lot of them don't get a chance to decide.
They're just kind of pushed into these camps.
It says,
imagine,
imagine the average salary is 500 a week.
If you're a famous boxer,
you might make 5,000 a week.
So there's this drive it,
if I can be just a normal Joe Bloggs cooking rice on the side of the road,
or if,
if I'm a famous boxer all of a sudden like could be the next toy version of
Floyd Mayweather,
like Saint,
like sandy soils,
uh,
Yo single and a bouquet or somebody.
So there,
there is,
um,
a chance to get out of poverty through fighting a guy like yachts and client.
Like how much does that guy make?
Like what's the equivalent American?
Not,
not,
not like,
not money,
but I mean like what is,
you know,
like whatever,
what it's worth in Thailand,
he's a Rockstar rockstar.
Like he has a nice house,
Nice cars.
Who knows it,
like with tires,
I don't know about that generation,
but like most Thai fighters I've known over the years,
they don't like know how to spend the money.
But there was a father,
I think he fought here in America the other day and I know him very well since I
was young.
I'm not going to say his name.
[inaudible] matches since I was about 20 and I saw him mom,
like,
you know,
he's fought in America.
It'd be making let's say $5,000 a flight.
It's a lot of money in Thailand.
And he still lives in just like a little shit.
Like who knows what they're doing with the money you give them the camp food
could descend,
you might send your mum and dad 30% and then you just live off that 20% until
you nix void.
And then you might drink that.
You might drink it and smoke it.
So when you say he's a rock star is not really a rock star.
I mean he's this famous,
he's comfortable financial.
Who's making all the money over there?
Uh,
the promoters,
camps,
promoters.
Yeah.
And the gambling is fascinating.
[inaudible] good,
good,
good.
Yeah.
Uh,
everyone's had their own bookmaker,
so you're watching two fights and watching red and blue.
And then after the first round,
it might be two for one for the red,
and then he's still winning round three it might be five for one and then five
for one was say if you bet a hundred,
a hundred baht oh five,
four one odds,
and then brown for all of a sudden Brie blue starts dominating.
And then that the odds that changing,
but you've already locked in your five for one this way.
So if you play in deciding all this stuff,
everybody's their input maker.
So you're in the crowd he's offering for,
for him.
But besides that guy's offering five one,
I'm going to go with him.
I'm going to kick these guys up.
And then you,
once you got your lock,
your bed on your lock,
eyes locked on,
done.
And then after the fights,
then you walk over.
Yep.
Got The money.
Cheers mate.
Thank you.
Wow,
that's interesting.
So it's completely unorganized chaos.
It's amazing.
It's controlled chaos.
That's what it sounds fascinating.
It's,
it's brilliant because,
uh,
sorta brewing because it's like going to the horse races.
Nobody cares about the fires.
Who Cares who wins?
You're seeing,
you're seeing crazy matches.
And then once you've got your bed on to now you're cheering this guy home,
like blood last,
final hydro,
couple hundred meters for horse race.
Go,
go gig.
And then they hear the crab.
Ooh,
Ooh.
It's just raise after every kick,
every punch.
And then,
um,
uh,
they have a thing called uh,
money injection.
So say you're losing the first three rounds and then they call it achieved.
Yeah.
So I'll give you,
I'll give you 50,000 back bonus in around four.
Tell him I'll give him $50,000 bonus if he wins by knockout.
And then how you another 50,000,
if you know what happened,
that thing froze again.
Yeah.
Did you call them after the last time?
It froze.
Hello?
Call them.
This is bullshit.
This is two out of 10 podcasts that thinks crashed on us.
Sorry.
We'll get the audio of it and we'll sync it all up with the use terms down.
Yep.
Um,
so I'm sorry,
don't mean to interrupt.
So they're,
they're screaming,
cheering,
50,000 bucks bonus.
So if you're,
if you're losing and then someone says,
I'll give you 50,000 if you win by knockout this next round,
all of a sudden you're tired,
you're losing,
and then 50,000 yeah.
All of a sudden you've got this second wind and you weren't to go out there and
hurt him and then you're knock him out and then the guy comes up,
here's your 50,000 I've just made 200,000 you can have 50,000 of it.
That's incredible.
So when this is all going on,
is that,
that's also why the ties tend to fight slowly in the first round.
The first round,
they kind of pace themselves.
It's almost like,
it's almost like you want to lose the first round and so the odds go to the
favor of the other corner.
You put the money on there,
your guy,
you might get your three for one,
or let's just for 10 for one,
he's losing bad.
He's getting his bash.
He's no way you can come back and then boom,
when's,
once he gets the,
the red light from the trainer and then he's on full steam ahead,
bump.
And that's the other way.
And you've just been so strange that the culture of fighting like this,
the sport,
the art itself is so,
so influenced by gambling.
And then what you have now is a,
well forever,
the muffling implements say they might,
they might say,
look,
you're earning 50,000,
but for noma flight we'll give you 300,000 fight.
If you happened that lady on round two by a head kick and knee,
and then,
uh,
say some you might be today,
Paul,
you're unbelievable.
And then the mafia might come along this actually do this.
And then Nixon around you don't know how to hold your hands up and then you get
hate keep.
And then the referer guys,
stop,
stop.
I've seen you fight 400 times.
You're a legend.
There's no way.
No,
you didn't know how to throw a jab.
A this flight is now considered a no contest and this will go to a church,
the church tribunal and you're looking at it at six months and net could be the
worst possible thing for any Thai boxing camp because now you bought dishonesty
and distrust and your camp,
his name is near mud.
Did you get,
hold on Zach,
does that happen all the time?
All the time.
At least five,
six,
seven times a week.
Five,
six,
seven times a week.
And how many times does that happen to you?
To me,
I'm there being offered money cause then I'm western so they know they can walk
over me if they try.
But I've seen it happen on toy TV so many times.
Halfway through the flight.
He know they can walk over you.
What do you mean?
Oh it just,
just a westerner.
If they know I'm beatable.
Where you've got to l um,
there's so many ties and Thailand that there's so many guys in the waiting line
that know they can,
like you had symbolize that,
haven't got a name that has just machines.
It,
it's hard to say.
Uh,
yeah,
I know.
I'm not elite that I,
I'm never going to be beaten.
So the tire just believe they can just walk over here.
But so because you're a westerner,
they believed in you so they don't offer you bribes to lose.
And there had been offered a bribe,
a guy like gods and Cli who's such a heavily favored fighter.
That would be the type of guy that they would try to influence.
Yeah.
That they'd probably asked you.
I'd single out a lay down before they'd asked me because he,
he's such a favorite to win.
So I'd be at the long shot and then if I won all of a sudden,
yeah,
it's crazy.
So for fighters like that is super critical to be involved in a very influential
camp so that you don't get asked to lay down.
Yeah.
If you are,
if you are one of the big gyms,
it made set,
let's pretend Tristar and all of a sudden George goes down from fighting someone
that he shouldn't and then all of a sudden tries to,
and I don't want to put Tristar goes on my show is anymore because,
uh,
they are obviously mafia influence,
so we don't want to deal with them anymore.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's crazy though.
The system over there.
So,
um,
so for long that's so,
uh,
that's so crazy that they have to think about that as well as fighting the best
fighters in the world and more tai and then they have to worry about being
influenced by gambling and by the Mafia.
Yeah.
But w w without saying any names or any camps.
I know of two,
I know of a camp in Thailand that two of the guys did happen to lay down and
bought this respect to the camp and um,
they might've passed away.
And then the,
for a certain amount of money,
um,
to the Thai police though,
that file goes missing.
And then it's just the warning to the other boxes that,
um,
it's not a good idea to lay down on from my gym.
Otherwise you could also go missing.
Wow.
Yay.
And I'm like,
great.
I'm not,
I'm not talking and rubbish data.
That's true stories.
Oh,
I'm sure.
I mean,
it only makes sense if you're talking about that amount of money you're talking
to you about.
The train is invested so much money in these fighters.
He's fed them,
he's looked at him,
he's given places to sleep,
and then they discredit him by,
by doing that to fill their own pockets.
Go,
well,
fuck you.
I'm going to,
I'll teach you a lesson.
One you'll never forget.
So what,
what kind of influence does the mafia have over Muay Thai in Thailand?
Other than that,
I mean,
there's,
obviously they're going to try to get people to fix fights,
but it,
was there any other influence that it has?
I mean,
how prevalent is it over there?
Oh,
I imagine,
imagine the,
um,
uh,
sometimes they're on the front of the TV and then the guy will have a clipboard
with velcro and he'll have 10 phones on a clipboard and you'll talk to everyone
at once.
Okay.
It's now seven,
four,
one for the blue corner.
And then some guy will have a emoc or when he's top pocket and it'll be blue.
And then the red starts turning around,
he techies [inaudible] and change it over to white and all of a sudden the
betting site is changing.
So there's all these different,
oh,
that's amazing.
It's so full on unless you know the,
the game and how to do it.
And I'm still learning.
I'm still watching things going,
holy shit,
this is in,
it's a different league of m sport.
Do they ever have issues with people not paying their desk?
Like people look at you and five to one or whatever the fuck they do the,
and then in big money,
so he might be a hundred thousand and 50,000 or 500,000 and all of a sudden,
yeah,
they might possibly go missing Lazzarini here.
So fascinating that that aspect of it and gambling in Asia seems so prevalent.
I mean all throughout the casinos here in America,
like she,
Alot of people from Asia,
a lot of Asian people gambling there.
And in Macau obviously they have the Macau they say is like way bigger than
Vegas.
Yep.
They say the gambling there,
it's just off the charts and people who were just stupid,
wealthy gambling ridiculous amounts of money.
But they have a,
a toy.
I'm way too white paper that comes at every day and they'll tell you that,
okay,
what's the odds are for each void?
It's annoying what the odds are.
A more,
uh,
who one big last night.
Uh,
it's,
it's all about gambling.
It's not about the fights where the matchups it's about,
uh,
making,
making mind gambling's illegal.
I think in Thailand,
Thai boxing day,
they turn a blind eye if you're playing,
if you're playing poker at home with them,
60,
mh from next door,
one of the other neighbors could look through the window,
bring the police,
and then they'll come in with six swat cars in air race,
everyone in the house.
From the kids to the grandparents from,
for playing poker in indoors in their own lounge room.
That's insane.
And this happens on a regular basis.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
They come in and arrest people for gambling with her family.
Yes.
That's insane.
But you can bet on the fights.
Wow.
And what's the,
what's the logic behind that is just seems to be,
for some reason there's seems to be a turn,
a blind eye and it's run by the army to the,
the big stadiums are run by the army to serve dinner.
Wow.
That's so fascinating.
So what did that to me has always been one of the most bizarre parts of more
time watching all those people screaming and bedding and throwing their hands up
in the air.
And me as someone who's never been over there,
I never understood what was going on.
Yup.
But it's crazy that you being over there,
I didn't know what was going on either and you're still trying to figure it out.
And after all these years,
I,
I've,
when I fought my first fight,
Olympia,
I was losing the first year round.
And then,
um,
I started landing a few key,
I must've been like 10,
four line 24,
one even.
And then,
uh,
I started landing a few punches and then the crowd just changed.
Bang.
And then,
um,
it was what got to the stage.
It was so deafening that it gives you that second wind.
Every time he landed shut,
all of a sudden it feels like you're invincible in there.
And then,
uh,
ended up knocking the garden at in the fourth round.
So I made every single one,
every single,
but all the guys in the,
in the stadium so much money,
cause it's 20,
put down 1000 bucks and you get a 20,000 back.
And he's like,
this is,
yeah,
it's pretty,
it's pretty cool.
So that is probably one of the reasons why it's so popular over there.
So it's like almost like their version of horse races.
Exactly,
exactly.
Wow.
Alone.
Pitney has gone now you were back then,
Long Pena like is the most family stayed in the world?
You are pretty much the only main western it was fighting heaps of wishing is
the Deca was there.
And,
um,
then he bill and even,
uh,
my new interest,
you know,
Maine,
he was right in their regular also,
but the tires are coming to the change room and instead of looking at it they'll
come and feel your arms like a horse.
See how fit you are.
Look you up and down like you're just a piece of meat.
Should I put money on him?
Yeah,
sure.
We looked pretty good when we looked a bit flabby.
Nah,
a bit on the other guy.
So just check you out and talking to and come and feel you and every hot sheet
touch your ability to see if you had a strong stomach.
These are just gamblers.
I just gamblers and then fucking weird and then edit them at long painting them
the change rooms next to the Thai toilets as well.
So as they're coming in for a pitch,
they might come in and fill your ass while you're pissing.
So what kind of rewards you got?
Pretty much.
Pretty Bizarre.
Did anybody ever get angry?
Like when people were touching him like that?
It's just so normal that it's not even frowned upon.
It's just like,
oh yeah,
hey going,
let's still do it today.
Yeah.
Similar.
They're just still do it today.
Yeah,
it's just normal.
It's just started culture.
Just there a lot of squeeze you.
Yay.
Pretty much.
How strange do they have women fighting over there?
It's just that I had before I started bed the last 10 years or something before
the ties.
The women,
even to this day,
I'll let it touch the ring on the main stadiums in,
in the,
in the country and the smallest things delay the flight,
but they've got to go under the bottom row.
Then I'll let her climb the top brick cause it's quiet when they get into the
ring and they must cop on their belly and Rolanda why?
Because and,
and then the old painting and the rigid them dunes,
they um,
they're not let it touch the ring yet because they give a girl gyms.
So you go girl,
go gyms and then I say in case you get cut.
Oh,
so you want to hear a funny one periods,
say the uh,
as a time male,
you know,
let it go down on a girl before I flight.
Otherwise there's a chance you'll get cut way.
Elbows,
good call.
Yeah.
I think that you get caught by elbows because,
because you've taken your head down past their waist and the head sacred and
below the waist is considered dirt.
So to go down on a girl is considered like really bad and really on bad luck.
But um,
I've had 290 stitches.
You've got 290 stitches.
That's a real number is rule number.
Great
fucking good connection with your dog.
They stitch you up properly.
I would have never guessed.
Um,
I've a rubber band in the back of my head.
There's pull the skin back.
It goes all the wrinkles yet.
That's crazy man.
290 stitches.
It's crazy that they won't let the girls touched the ring.
Like what do they do when they're fighting?
Uh,
on,
uh,
on the ad side one side,
they used to make the girls fight last,
so there was no girl germs when the boys fought,
so wow.
But before they couldn't touch the ring it at all.
So,
but everything's backup.
Jamie been up for awhile.
That's bizarre.
That's so strange that they have such ancient,
ridiculous superstitious ideas when it comes to women.
Yeah.
Tom,
what happened then?
I'm doing the lady boy,
the lady boy,
they used to fight a long painting.
Uh,
they made a movie about her cause she used to save all the prize money and then
she eventually saved up enough to get a sex change.
And then,
uh,
she started doing the homeowners.
Then it was all over the news because,
um,
she started taking these injections,
then bait make boobs and then she wouldn't take your shirt off when she fought.
And then she was a big spectacle.
She was making a main events in Japan,
but she stopped fighting and toiling and cause you didn't want to fight other
boys.
And now that paying like thousands of dollars just have dinner with her because
she was such a freak.
Oh he was such a freak.
And then I eventually,
after they said we've got to give you an injections gray,
the boobs,
make sure you want to say exchange first.
Uh,
before we chop it,
you doodle off.
And then they eventually dropped the doodle off and now a cheap flights chicks.
But because she's had all the hormones now she doesn't heat.
It was hot.
Well,
no,
she's not as good as she was.
She's lost that testosterone.
Would you say she's a based,
just still fucking up in la?
Not as much.
Not as,
not as much.
She's not as tough as she used to be.
Well she used to
teach to be fucking totally different.
So she's allowed to fight females.
Yes.
Well she has this white females now.
Does she lose sometimes?
Wow.
But yeah,
I wanted the photo back or knows entirely and oh,
but back when
she was a heat,
of course he did.
Yeah.
He wouldn't fight me cause I was a little bit of a threat.
And so he'd fight.
And then he got to the stage where he'd only fight Westerners or Japanese
because,
uh,
they were a bit easier than other ties.
Wow.
So was that the first person that's become a transgender fighter over there?
I believe so.
The most famous,
anyway,
he,
and then he started going on catwalk models cause he had the,
the Jiggle and he's Bra the Jiggle in his Bra.
Yeah.
Well the,
the gets a rap song.
Wow.
Yeah.
Um,
I fought him.
He was not like worldclass before.
No,
it wasn't,
it wasn't a cost if the probably be class.
And how amongst women,
what classes she now when,
when it was,
uh,
Jess before the operation it big,
big style in Japan main event,
a lot of big shows.
And um,
before the operation at one time they,
they made her fight a female rock and roll wrestler that never thrown a punch
before.
And they put boxing gloves and then she had them,
the,
the face painted up in the wrestling stuff and had the guitar,
they get up with the Lycra and then,
um,
the,
the bill when the rest of their come charging across the transgender,
I grabbed it by the back of the neck,
elbow to three times in the face and knocked her out unconscious for about two
or three minutes.
It didn't go well.
And the dots before the white crew that like John was talking about,
um,
I think she does the lipstick on the mirror there.
That's pretty cool.
Claims the head.
So she fought a woman that had never fought,
never done any training,
is beating the shit out of her and knocked her out.
The toy was about 66,
67 in the female wrestlers,
about 80 or 90 kilos.
So looking at it,
it look fair.
One was big,
one was more when you had a flight,
when you had to wrestle,
but in a moist high match.
Oh,
it didn't go well.
It was at Japan is Japan.
Japan's crazy way.
Japan's amazing.
They love it.
They love doing that and they love having people who have never fought before
fight someone who's a world champion,
like they do weird shit like that.
They always did weird shit like that and pride and k one a dream.
Bob Sapp and the hung main joy days.
Yeah man,
it's full.
They had a lot of crazy matchups.
Bob Sapp was a part of a lot of them but they love putting that guy up against,
I mean they put Bob's hop against her.
Nesto hoost only beat him twice.
I just with steroids just with steroids and a lot of momentum and mean.
He's tough.
Look,
he took some fucking beatings.
I mean Ernesto,
who's some buyer and pride,
that was a good fight.
That was exciting.
Fucked up.
Noguera's NANC forever.
Oh really?
Pile driver.
He hit him with a pile driver in the first round.
He was 370 pounds with abs and Nogueira you know to this day is next.
Probably fucked up from that fight.
I remember a cro cop was the first person that the beat him in.
I'm Caitlyn came with that head kick.
Well,
he broke his eye socket.
Oh really?
Yeah,
he,
uh,
he hit him with straight left and fractured his eye socket.
It wasn't a headcase.
Okay.
Yup.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
And then he went down and he crumbled.
Yup.
I remember that one.
Yeah,
he's his,
I was never the same after that.
He had like one of those weird highs after that,
you know,
some dudes get some dudes if their I gets their orbital gets so shattered that
they have to repair it and do reconstructive surgery on it.
Whatever you're doing is picking up on the microphone over there.
Fellow you eat nuts,
put,
just push it away from me here.
Um,
but he,
uh,
he's,
I like,
he had one eye that was always like really weird after that.
And because of that,
like he pretty much never was willing to take a punch after that.
Like from then on,
like all of his fights,
he started like kind of laying down and he,
whenever he got tagged,
fight was over.
There was no comeback money.
Fuck.
Yeah,
he did.
He made a lot of money when he was a super star in Japan.
I mean they,
they made a,
a boob set.
Um,
I do.
They,
they,
they did,
they molded it and um,
they,
that would end the Japanese loved it.
They thought it was the greatest thing ever.
They molded it after his dick or just apparently says serious.
He said that they had a book,
they had a book of 50 bubs at facial expressions.
Here's Bob happy.
He's,
Bob said he's raising one eyebrow and it was a,
it was like a number one seller.
He was the dulls the,
the bulbs.
That was a big deal.
That's so there are so strange and unusual,
unusual culture.
You have any weird things that sold in Japan?
Uh,
it just always men crying.
That was the,
probably the weirdest thing when we used to go to a hotel,
uh,
there'd be people that had came in the foil for like three or four days and
every time we come in and lift that old sort of rush up to the thing,
trying to get pictures and signings and um,
sometimes walking the street I had to at one mile guy,
he just broke down in front of me and just had a ball and he's always,
yeah.
And then um,
he pulled out of what Chad these pockets and I was coming to the hotel to give
you this.
I can't believe I'm meeting you on the street.
He has this watch and just Yay.
It was bizarre.
And then women crying too.
Like women would cry all the time.
That was sort of normal.
That's normal in pro wrestling circles.
If you follow American pro wrestler.
Yeah,
yeah.
They'll start crying.
Yo,
if they meet you
fanatics,
it's just fanatics.
It's just Japanese fanatics are different than any other fanatic.
They're very strange.
It's cool.
But it's,
it's,
it's fun.
It's a chip plan was fun.
I got to fight the 16 told him to say when,
um,
yeah,
it was,
it was awesome.
Well,
the culture is very bizarre when you're walking around there and you just walk
around Tokyo.
It doesn't feel like any other city anywhere else.
It's very modern.
It's very advanced,
very technologically advanced.
Like everything is like neon and big screens and high def,
this and that and,
but everybody's like super polite.
Everything super clean.
Sometimes you gotta three feds too where people would have silver hair and the
next time you got back everyone would be tane like ridiculous orange.
Well the next time you go back it'd be something else where their head,
the the loud and I bet it was just,
yeah.
Bizarre.
Like I said,
well that's one of the things that happen with fighting over there,
right?
Yeah.
Fighting was a big fat.
It was only thousand people in Tokyo Dome Down to 40,000 people to pretty much
disappeared from donor.
How do your heady I mess up and promotion that's got 90,000 people hideous.
Screw that up or k one doesn't exist anymore.
Right.
It's done.
Sort of coming back a little bit,
but it's not what it was.
It'll never be what it was.
When was the last event?
Oh,
I think they,
they're doing a 63 killer now where,
but they might only get 5,000 people compared to the old days of the forties in
the 60s in the hunter and the nineties so it's never going to have the same
appeal book.
Before.
When we used the fight Keller Mix,
I believe the promotion paid 50% and the TV paid 50% said between them,
they just made this super promotion,
so it was the big buildup on the TV and then all the graphics and the highlights
and they fly to Australia.
They interview me.
I'm like,
like the USC does say all the fans felt like they knew the fighter before the
bill rent,
so,
and that's,
that's what the f the sports needs for the mortar in the kickboxing.
It certainly does.
It's just,
it's so strange that in Japan that was like this insanely high level of
popularity.
And then just the Bob sat and the earnest hoose and the Peter Urges.
There'd be on all the game shows and then there'd be an old will,
a fortunate in Japan sorta stole.
And that was just celebrities that were not just fighters but celebrities.
And then that's all just vanished.
Now what's replaced it?
Um,
there's no combat sports that are particularly popular there right now.
They will,
the pride pride in pride was so massive and one was so massive.
And what's in the,
I'm not sure simmer.
The UFC got totally schooled in Japanese business when they bought pride.
Yup.
Because they really didn't understand how much different Japanese business is
than American business.
Like one of the things they did was,
it's really kind of interesting how they did it.
The,
the Japanese would talk about selling pride.
They'd be like,
you know,
we would like to sell pride.
And they go,
okay,
let's,
let's sit down.
Let's talk,
let's go over numbers.
And so they'd make this big announcement.
The UFC sitting down with prior,
they're talking about buying pride and then they go,
we're not going to sell.
And they would,
they would sit down,
they'd get,
they'd reach some sort of an agreement and then not going to tell.
I went for a long time.
They're like,
what the fuck is going on with these guys?
Like they say they're going to sell and they don't sell.
But what they were doing was,
I mean they had Vandelay Silva come over and he got in the cage with chocolate
Dell and they mean mug each other.
We're not going to sell.
And what they did was they hyped up pride through the UFC and they made pride
more exciting by pretending that they were going to sell prior to the UFC by
pretending they were gonna bring fighters over.
And fighters are going to fight in pride.
And they had chocolate.
Dell go over and fight in pride.
Remember that?
And you know rampage Jackson and chocolate del fought.
And then chuck came back to the UFC and then finally they said they were going
to sell pride and they sold it for $65 million.
Okay.
The UFC got it.
And once they went through all the paperwork,
all the monies exchanged hands,
they realized they'd bought bullshit because all the contracts were invalid.
There were all bullshit contracts,
there were all w w didn't hold up.
So like they didn't have faith or they didn't have a lot of its stars like,
and they had a video library,
that's all they had.
They got a video library for like $65 million.
Then it gets even crazier.
So they say,
okay,
we're going to run pride in Japan,
we're going to maintain the office in Japan and we're gonna use these pride
employees.
We're going to build up pride,
we're going to start running plot pride in Japan.
So these time they'd start trying to do that.
And the people that were working for them started dream.
So they're working for them,
they're working for the UFC and,
and all the while they're putting together this dream promotion.
And so then they went off and started dream and then you know the UFC,
he's like,
ah,
we're just going to close up shop.
So now all they had from that $65 million,
I think they were going to try to sue Japan.
Like the Japanese businessmen.
It's old to them.
It was a big deal for a while,
but then they dropped that shit too.
And now all they have is like the best of pride that's on like Fox sports one.
I mean that's the revenue source and it's,
it's also like something they show on on a fight pass.
Like you could watch all the old prides on fight pass,
which is Kinda cool.
But it's like,
fuck man.
It's just,
they're just,
it's just different.
She's very different over there.
It's crazy.
Did you make good money fighting over there?
Uh,
it's that of the ball rolling.
It's that a definitely got me out of them.
Yeah,
it helps.
It helps that.
And then once I started getting,
no,
you Katelyn money then is it sort of snowballed,
which helped me get to where I am now.
Did they give you it all in cash like they do with the,
uh,
the MMA fighters is one of those ones where as a month wait in between
paychecks.
Yeah.
You'd fight and,
okay.
Where is it?
Well that's one of the things,
it's that fuck Bob Sapp over.
Bob Sapp was um,
they had some sort of a contract dispute and they tried to get him to fight
without a contract in the main event of one of their events.
Is it in Holland?
I don't think it was.
It was a Japanese event.
I know he walked out of one of the events in Holland and paid it,
which was in the crowd after a few bees and he ended up putting his hand out,
said,
oh fine,
I'll save the shitter.
And he did it.
He got,
but he took it.
He took what?
He had to borrow someone else's shorts.
[inaudible]
after a couple of beers.
Yeah.
It's hilarious.
Peter Arts man.
You want to talk about a dude who's fought the best of the best forever.
Yeah.
He's the King God.
That guys had some crazy fights.
I watched a highlight reel of his the other night on Youtube and you forget,
you forget how many high kick Kaos that guy had got,
I bet to say the same thing as the cause critical ups got the reputation for the
head.
But then you look back at Peter Hertz,
there's Cro,
cop has a reputation for head kicks in MMA.
Yep.
But in kickboxing you mean there's no comparison between cro cop and Peter
Hertz.
Yup.
But it's also cro.
Cop had a really good style for MMA.
Yeah.
Because he's like this explosive sprinter type dude.
Like his style for kickboxing.
He might've not had the best style to compete against like the Anesto who sir
the the best kickboxer guys.
Like they were like a little bit more tactical than him.
They had a little bit more classic kickboxing training.
You know,
he's over in Croatia,
but he's just a savage,
you know,
and just had lightening fast kicks that left high kick band.
Jesus Christ.
He was a good guy for winning.
Went to pray because we had someone that we could relate to that was doing so
well in MMA.
It's like,
yes,
everyone,
everyone cheated for critical because he was one of us pro that the going over
well you got to see with Cro cop what happens when you get a really high level
kickboxer and they learn how to sprawl and they learn how to stay on their feet.
Everybody was getting fucked up.
I mean there was a period of time when cro cop was in his prime where mean
before he lost to fade or,
I mean he was just lighting people on fire.
You know,
you look at some of his head kick victories and prime,
they had,
this dude's had no business standing up with him.
They had no business.
It was like they were blue belts and he was like a ninth degree black belt and
striking.
He would just fucking head kick everybody do oblivion,
but he didn't have that kind of sexy success in kickboxing.
Yeah.
It's sort of like what we were talking about earlier,
where when you're fighting,
when you see guys that are fighting and kickboxing and Muay Thai and you're
seeing the highest level expression of that art of,
of striking art,
like the yachts and Clive's the bull cows.
Yup.
John Wayne Pars.
Who was you think,
um,
your toughest opponents?
Have you ever fought a,
you guys think Les Johnson Class?
I fought him three times.
The first time I fought him he,
um,
he kicked me in the head,
uh,
the second round and then like last night when I told him I,
Brendan,
I couldn't remember the rest of the fight went the distance,
but I have no idea what happened off of the head kick.
And then the second time we fought was the funnel of the contender ratio,
like reality TV show.
And he dropped me around one and then drove me to get me on to,
and I did okay.
Three,
four and five.
But um,
yeah,
he,
he's a beast.
In the third time I fought was down in Melbourne and I was done.
I was just lucky enough to the,
the punches with,
it's the Australian judges scored a little bit high than the round kicks in and
if it was entirely,
and I think I would've lost,
but because it was in Australia,
I was lucky to get the single victory I room today.
That's interesting though because the,
it's kind of arbitrary,
like they decide that the punches don't score as much in Thailand.
Like the only way you can score,
I don't think you mentioned on this podcast,
but you talked about it yesterday and the fight pass that a guy could like box
the shit out of a tie fighter and ty was kicking his arms.
The tie fighter would win.
Yeah,
well I felt bull Kaylee in Jamaica and they had three Lupini judges,
they and then everyone that watches the phone,
I get a lot of emails
to this day that just watch it on Youtube and say,
ah,
I think you'd beat balk at that time.
But because it was the toy influence with the judges in the toy scoring that
that's how I lost.
But it would've been nice to have that one victory over board cows.
Well that would really sort of shot,
cause he's,
he's a man now he's meeting more famous [inaudible] even though I think you got
single,
I would beat book and I've never fought.
Well he,
yeah,
he still,
so I got to see a chance to see him fight once in Los Angeles.
Three,
I forget the name of the promotion,
but they had a really high level,
a Artem Levon fought a book.
How far but to see him fight live was yeah,
he doesn't hit very hard compared to you singular and he's very fast,
but you guys away,
it's very powerful.
And South Pole.
So you had single,
I'd bring in Goodson guys punching in defenses worlds.
The end of tours he's punches crazy or is um,
both cows realizing that fast left kick in fast team.
So it'd be,
so it's one of those Floyd packy,
our fights,
the yard,
single adverse balking or fight.
But I,
I'd put my money if they ever did happen to meet,
is it too late for those guys to fight a different promotion?
So I,
different promoters,
sorry.
So too much support politics that learned on Bob Arum donkey never going to
happen.
God dammit.
And then borecas on your contract now where he's,
he's not allowed to fight other ties apparently.
Yay.
He's got taken over by seeing how beer they've taken every,
as management in,
um,
they've made some,
some contract where we can find out the toys anymore.
That's ridiculous.
How can we can't fight it other times.
I think it's got to the stage now where he's become a brain.
He's not just a fighter.
He's a,
he's a brand.
He's the,
he uh,
he sponsored by sing her,
um,
Thai Airways,
uh,
Thai tourism.
Uh,
he's the face of the Thailand for the Moitai.
It's amazing how that happened.
He's Ah,
because he got ripped off by his old manager.
He had about 200 fights for a pauper book and then he won the k one two or three
times to two times when $50,000,
$100,000,
both times.
And then,
um,
he kept asking his trainer,
so it has my money go,
oh,
don't worry.
I've put in the bank.
I'm an investment with Voya.
And he went out and bought five houses for himself and then board the manager,
the manager,
the mom of four.
And then he said,
okay,
where's my money?
He said,
ah,
you have nothing you had,
he had a pillow and a suitcase of clothes after,
after 200 fights to show for his name.
Wow.
So he quit.
He quit the camp and he said,
Betsy,
I'm done.
And then,
um,
the manager was going to sue him.
I went to court and I told a,
yeah,
it was big time managers going to sue him because he's still one of these 50%.
If,
if walk out,
if both,
if Bork care went to fight for Japan again,
he was still making big money and he still won and he's cut even though he was
ripped them off,
even though he's ripping them off.
He the entirely and the manager was still bright.
He still had the rights.
It was his horse.
Remember how we're talking about the horses?
That's still,
that's his property.
[inaudible] property book didn't have any claim to all the money that he got
ripped off from.
Nothing.
Whoa.
Thailand.
Okay.
So he leaves and then somebody else manages say,
boy cow.
He declared statement.
Remember the fight night,
any thought the king in and said,
you know,
I've fought for my country,
a fight for the king and
holding your hands up like you're holding a photo.
He did.
He was holding a photo of it,
king
calling him up and then I think he and Nancy,
his retirement.
So he said,
I'm done.
I'm just gonna Open Moon Gym.
And then,
uh,
the,
I believe seeing how BIA they felt,
they had a friendship with him and I said,
hey,
we're going to take your now wings will counter sued.
They got the money to do whatever.
And then Bork Ella had permission to all of a sudden they start fighting again.
And then,
um,
they have a lot of influence.
So the entire tourism come in and said,
oh,
we'll give you a hand as well,
and that all these other sponsors.
And then all of a sudden walking out,
I was driving a BMW and energies are in place and it is a good face for like,
well where does he live?
He's live still in Thailand.
He's where?
He's at camp now.
He's in Thailand.
In Thailand.
It is on a farm.
I was saying with the farm pictures,
he's got a massive gym.
Well that's a great story.
That this terrible tragedy in this horrible turn.
Good.
Yeah.
They're still young.
I mean how old is he?
I must be nearly early thirties probably.
So that age where it's like almost,
you know,
he's got enough time.
Yeah.
It was the full rocky story and his whole position positions taken away and then
they come back and now to be to where he is is pretty cool.
And he's the only fighting Westerners.
Like how's it go?
Yeah,
Western is and um,
uh,
Asians but no toys.
That's so weird.
Why no ties.
Dangerous.
He could lose.
Lose.
He's a brand.
Oh,
I didn't think of it that way.
I thought it was a nationalistic thing.
You don't want to beat a lot of Brazilians.
Do not like to fight Brazilians as the,
the handful of toys that are there that are quite,
quite dangerous as well.
And then could take away that and then that reputation and when flight is
disappeared,
uh wow.
Whew.
That's a terrible little velvet present to be living in it,
you know,
that's,
does that make him lose faith in,
in Thailand or in the only Thai community?
He's a god.
Doesn't matter.
As he going every time he fights,
there'll be 20,000 people in a park somewhere cheering his name.
How am I any,
uh,
just for instance,
like the,
we were talking about before,
how if you can do a promotion yet people will drive for hours to be amongst,
to be amongst the promotion.
And then,
um,
I think he's on top commercials.
They might even be on the side of buses and billboards.
And he's,
he's the man.
He's like,
he,
he's the,
what could he be?
He's the Michael Jordan of Thailand.
So does yachts and Clyde's sit around looking at him on billboards and go,
damn,
motherfucker.
Pretty Mellow.
I daresay he would,
he'd have to.
You'd have to damn.
Cause those are the two big names that people talk about in Muay Thai.
In America.
I mean,
I don't know what it's like over there,
but when you talk to people who train my tie that are fans of the sport,
those are the two big names.
Yeah.
Bull care.
I had the opportunity to fight for Kaitlin,
which blueys career up before that and he was just fighting on channel seven.
Just this,
I'm a
small time.
And then got in front of the Caitlin walled scene and then he blew up.
And then you had single,
I never had the same opportunities as Bork,
how I did four yards and Clive's finding for lion fights.
Right?
Yeah.
And they're putting that on access TV.
It's,
it's,
it's just not that much a coverage.
Yes.
It's too bad.
Cause Access TV has amazing fights in lion fight.
You know,
like they have Kevin Ross.
Yes.
Who's a American that does very well.
It's one of their champions over there.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Really exciting to watch.
Fight.
Yeah.
Kevin is cool.
He's so good.
And it's more tie.
It's such pure Moyie Thai,
you know what I mean?
It's not like a a boxer,
a kickboxer like there's some guys like no disrespect cause he's a very good
fighter.
Like a Wayne Barrett is a very good fighter,
but you know,
you see like he's got more of a sort of like a boxing style and then he's adding
the Moitai techniques to it.
Whereas you see Kevin Ross like just looks like,
you know your classic yes.
Thai style of fighter given sort of like the vision of me.
He's going and lived and breathed and then everything and he's power to make
that,
that transition.
So his whole life consumed of the,
yeah.
I love lion fights,
man.
I,
I went to see that live live in Vegas.
I really hope that promotion takes off.
Yes,
it'd be good for the sport and it'd be so good.
Well the,
this is the only one.
I mean there's,
there's,
that's the big promotion in America.
That's the promotion with TV coverage is showing full Muay Thai.
Yes.
Yeah.
So you got brought in to work with George.
You got brought in to work with George Saint Pierre before,
which fight was it?
Hendrix.
Yeah.
And what was that camp like and what was it like?
Like how did you guys make this connection?
Uh,
so I had the opportunity to come to Canada and I did a seven seminars.
We'll all around Canada and there was about three days left and wade scheduled
before it had the flood back to Australia.
And then the gentleman the boat may have,
I said,
hey,
would you like the trouble to Montreal?
And I get a choice that I make George a holy shit.
That'd be pretty cool.
Get up,
get a photo with George and a Facebook status and they'd be amazing.
So we drove,
we drove to him Montreal and I said,
Hey,
um,
Flores was so nice.
He goes,
I know he,
well,
I'm happy to put you up in a hotel for tonight.
And then tomorrow is moist high spine day.
Would you let this spa,
a few of the boys said,
Holy Shit,
that'd be pretty cool.
So the next day I'm bought all my gear and then,
uh,
we're,
we're stretching out.
And say,
hi,
John Wayne,
you go and spy George.
I was like,
whoa.
And then,
uh,
I,
I touched George's,
his glove,
and then I was like,
this little school girl.
Oh my God,
I can't believe it was Rogers with George it up movement.
It's like I did,
we used today exactly the same I think with you today.
And then,
uh,
and then the first 10 seconds I was so afraid,
or George's Jab.
And then I've waited,
waited,
and then he's throwing something.
I Cannady through something else I can under that.
Um,
he threw a jab,
I come over the top and I placed my shin across his neck and I just left it
there,
just long enough for the whole gym to stop in and stay.
And then,
um,
and then George's eyes lit up.
And then,
uh,
and then I chased him from one side of the cage,
the sort of the cage.
And,
uh,
it was pretty,
I felt pretty good.
And then a next round,
hey,
all right,
John Wayne,
or you got a Rory.
So I sparred Rory and as a high shit,
um,
I said the jury,
Rory,
I,
hello,
how are we going to go?
Like,
cause I thought he was a pretty sight psycho and now he was really cool.
He was really nice guy and then we spot him and um,
they really well against Roy's,
well I bank with George so that did really well against George again.
So I took some photos and then,
um,
I thought that was,
that was it.
And I thought we were done.
And then about two months later,
whereas gave me a call and he said,
hey,
George is getting ready for Hendrix.
What about two months?
Any chance you want to come back to Montreal and train George personally?
From what I,
it's a holy fuck.
Yes.
Wow.
Sorry.
I jumped on the plane.
George picked me up at the airport.
He took me to the hotel.
He said,
oh,
this is the,
the hotel and uh,
Saint Catherine's,
uh,
this is where I like the heat.
Freddie Roach.
It's like,
Holy Shit,
this is big time.
Yeah.
George picked me up every morning.
We go train,
we'd go eat lunch and water together and every,
every day for two hours after,
after a week he said,
hey,
do you want to go to New New York?
New York's like my second hometown.
I'd love to show you around.
We'll go and meet John Donahue that then,
uh,
here.
Um,
so we went to New York and then we did some training at the Gracie Academy
there.
And,
uh,
I got to meet Phil nurse and then,
it was,
it was really cool.
Everyone was real you training Jujitsu or know just training.
I was training,
I was Georges Moitai trainer personally for two weeks.
Uh,
for us it's,
you don't have to do any classes or any cinema,
cinema seminars.
Well it just got to train joy's personally for two weeks.
So basically everyday,
everyday,
everyday we'll do pet pads in a spa and just have fun.
Did you do anything differently the way you train him then you would train any
more Thai fighter?
Uh,
we had to get ready for the Hendricks who was a south pole.
So I become Hendrix when we sparred.
So I'd throw this,
um,
this overhand right and trying to rush him along and then less,
sorry.
Yes,
very good.
Very cool.
Um,
that's why you're on the big bucks.
So yeah,
I've become a Hendrickson when we spot.
And then,
uh,
I had George just doing basic stuff as you would have fire fighting any Sao
Paulo.
But,
uh,
unfortunately I think for nurses at my stall didn't compliment Phil's store.
Phil was more about the spinning kick in the jumping elbow and the,
and the spinning something or other.
And I just want him to keep George one stall just to keep it inside.
Right.
You just wanted it to be like more conservative.
Yeah.
And then,
um,
uh,
so after two weeks,
it was still 12 weeks before the fight happened.
So George went,
probably went back to these stall because you'd say hard,
you've got to stay with someone that whole time.
You can't just train them for a couple of days and hope that they stay that way.
Um,
and then,
so I got back to Australia and this is cool.
So this lady,
she,
she sends me this email,
she goes,
I'm just want to know,
are you going to go to Georges fight?
And I said,
oh,
unfortunately,
no.
If I go on the team,
they're going to have to kick someone off and I don't want to cause any
controversy.
I'm the,
I'll just share for George in Australia.
She goes,
no,
no.
You deserve to be there.
Um,
I want to pay for your plane ticket to go and which George fight live.
You deserve to be there.
Who's this lady?
It just some lady from,
from Facebook,
some cash and then,
uh,
wow.
So she just flew you.
So she goes,
what would you like Iowa window?
And I say,
Holy Shit,
this is really happening.
She goes,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
I'll,
I'll send you over there.
You deserve to be there.
And then she goes,
good news.
Um,
as I was looking for flights,
they deal came up for MGM.
So I've got your three nights at the MGM also.
So you just got to rock up and I'm going crazy.
It was so cool.
And George,
no,
you were common.
Uh,
no,
I don't think so.
Well,
I seen I then,
um,
Goya from Mexico that trains at Albuquerque.
He,
um,
he seen I was there and he asked me if I could walk him to the scales on the
night and then I got to see George in the back room and he's looking at me,
how the hell did you get that?
But that's fine.
It was pretty cool.
And that's when we met.
Yeah.
So that's how I got your tickets.
That's how you got it as a fight.
So everybody hooked you up.
Yes.
It was amazing.
Um,
and then,
yeah,
watching George fight from the grand stands for the complete opposite fight to
what we're training for.
He fought,
he fought Hendrix like he was gonna Fight Orthodox fighter instead of a southpaw
fighter.
So he's turning outside,
outside,
left kicks and set it inside the right kicks in.
Big Body kicks up.
We're working on,
but um,
he still,
but I thought he won.
It was a very close fight.
I thought going into the fifth round,
it was anyone's fight.
It was two,
two,
and the fifth round.
I believe George just slightly enough to get the edge.
So that's my theory anyway.
But you didn't enjoy,
um,
the way he was doing it.
You'll get it bother you.
Yeah,
it did a little bit.
Consider all we worked on and then how he fought was um,
yeah,
a complete contrast.
So I think he could have won a lot easier if we had stuck to our game plan.
But um,
yeah,
I I was too far out of camp to,
to make that game plan stick.
I did another film nurse wiped a lot of spinning techniques.
Like what,
what yeah,
you're kind of spinning techniques as he,
uh,
he's more about the spinning elbows in the APP would elbow and the spinning back
kick.
He's more about the,
the,
the crowd pleasing moves instead of the,
the sticking to the basics.
That's interesting.
I wouldn't have thought that.
I thought he was like real traditional Moitai
more flashy,
more flushing.
But he,
he's the one that gets the,
the,
the crowd standing up.
He,
when,
when people do he stuff it's,
it's the,
it's the eye.
Yeah.
That's pretty awesome.
Oh,
I see where it's at.
I'd rather punch someone in the face really hard with the jab,
you know,
would spinning Becky if that makes him.
So I'll,
I'll keep,
I'll keep everything low key so I can win instead of risking will you have a
real power based style,
which was really unusual.
I've,
I've worked with a lot of different guys over the years that uh,
training MMA fighters or Trey Moy Tai and your style was,
is completely unique.
Like this,
your style of standing,
your style,
like your fucking,
that power jab you have is ridiculous man.
It's really the only guy who I've ever talked to that had a similar philosophy
but slightly different was bas Rutten bas route.
And also believes that your,
your jab should be as hard as you left as your right hand.
You want to be.
He's a fucking psycho going here.
Best written stories say so.
Uh,
you have a bus route,
the bus route and story,
these knee lane.
And then I was with the family and then,
uh,
I've going to go to the toilet and I've seen best with his family.
And now I was around a UFC shit.
And then,
uh,
end of the quote on quote on my oil,
I could see that he seen me and I was sorta this little thing,
this little sparrow,
this little,
it's a little annoying little bug.
That shit.
How long ago was this?
Ah,
maybe two or three years ago.
Oh,
ignoring little bug that happened to have 10 world titles.
I had the UFC shirt on,
so I stood at like,
Doug was bowls and then I finally got the courage.
They got up and asking you for a photo and then,
um,
he said,
oh,
I'm just a minute.
Just a minute.
I have to buy my son and the ice cream first.
I'll come back.
And I felt this big,
I felt like a little midget.
And then I'm sure why not be come back over here.
I'll get that photo with the now.
And I've,
I felt he didn't know who I was.
I introduced myself,
but he's just what I just the polite small,
took the photo,
wished me on my way and then,
uh,
and then he came to Australia and then he did it seminars here and the guy that
organized seminars got him to give me a call.
Hey,
talked to John Wayne,
he's bit of,
and then I told him this story and it was,
it was pretty funny.
But yeah.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Did you say your name to him?
I told anyone I shut him.
John Wayne par.
Uh,
he gave me a polite,
so smaller,
you're going to be a polite small loss route and out of the loop.
Yeah.
He was the first guy to bring like real technical striking to MMA.
He's amazing.
He's the main bachelor's,
the main him.
And then Maurice Smith was the one who brought like real hard level more tie to
the UFC.
Yes.
You know,
like you watch a Maurice's leg kicks were just fucking brutality.
He gives them,
the minute I touch up to 30.
Yes.
Maurice was a bad motherfucker in his day.
He want to fight recently at 50 he's 50 and he won a MMA fight by head Keck.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Wow.
I mean,
he's still going at it,
man.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
Maurice just decided,
I took a few years off.
He decided to fight one more time and,
and that was MMA.
Yeah.
You ever married?
He fought some dude who I had no booze,
no other way,
you know?
But I mean,
hey mean he's 50 you don't know.
You know,
I mean,
there's guys that have come back after all those years and she,
you know,
Maurice was in great shape.
He did it the right way.
He was,
he was always known for his discipline and his cardio.
Yeah.
He's,
well,
when we're talking about pioneers,
just before,
he was definitely one of the main,
oh yeah,
they brought the sport up.
Well,
he was one of the first guys that showed how important cardio wasn't MMA and
when he fought Mark Coleman,
because Mark Coleman came out,
I'm like off fucking bat out of hell on the first round,
but more.
He's just so,
it showed poise and discipline and stay calm and then after,
you know,
the first round was over and call them and start a gas out.
Then more he starts laying those heavy leg kicks.
You hear that,
that fucking disgusting baseball bat to meet sound.
Oh yeah.
It's just,
it's been very interesting to see the rev,
the evolution of a,
the standup striking in MMA now for a guy like you standing on the outside and
watching.
This has got to be really interesting for you too,
because you know,
coming from that pure striking background and seeing all the things that MMA
fighters and you know,
in,
in the standup aspect,
w would they do that?
They do wrong.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
What works in my sport doesn't work in MMA.
You can't throw body kicks really in MMA otherwise and catch it and take you
straight to the end.
There's a lot of guys winning by body kick.
Now a lot of guys are stopping guys,
especially with that left kick to the liver man that left kick to the body when
they're standing the south pole position.
You're seeing Liotta Machita one by that.
There's a lot of guys are winning by that kick the Steven Seagal tapes in the
face.
No,
that ones,
that's rare.
But man,
that fucking shit works.
You know,
it's weird.
Tepes very rarely knock anybody out in my tie tapes in MMA.
Yeah.
Well we were talking,
we'll do a few guys do,
but we were talking about it last night that the stance is so different in MMA
and you're still worried about the take downs and you know,
the grasp,
the grappling aspect.
You might open the door to front kicks and things along those lines.
And it's my,
um,
one of my main weapons in.
I wouldn't be able to throw it how the as much when I kind of have it to America
to try and learn a little bit of MMA.
I had,
um,
I had a flight back in 2017 it's a gentleman gluteny been yellow and then I got
over here and then everything like I tried to do.
That's how I kind of do that.
You kind of do more than three or four punches,
otherwise you're gonna get taken down.
You kind of buddy,
keep not catching you take it in as a coach is telling.
Yeah.
And they've got to the stage where it's like,
what's your coach?
Who's the coach telling me that?
Uh,
Thomas Denny.
Hmm.
Okay.
Yeah.
So he's a good dude.
You should have been with a guy like for us,
you know,
I get the garlic for us.
Would have figured out what to do with looking back.
Looking back,
I was,
I was just,
um,
he was closest to my wife's family,
so it just seemed,
makes sense.
I'm actually,
uh,
actually chatting with them.
The guys down at,
uh,
Orange County.
I know Orange County.
what's,
um,
Eric Paulson,
Paulson,
lot of crazy grappling.
He's got a lot of like cat trust as a Fewster drive.
Uh,
so I to hear a funny story.
Sure.
So I,
um,
I meet Cub Swanson.
Cub Swanson is cool dude,
and they're hanging out.
And then my first day,
Eric Paulson,
steam,
uh,
it's more tidy.
Okay.
And I'm the,
I'm the new guy.
I had no nothing,
no one knows who I am.
And then it's like I post,
I was like,
okay,
more taco has put your gear on guys.
Okay.
So,
uh,
Josh Net,
you spa this way.
And he points to me.
And uh,
so I always thought,
and I'll move it around inside kick,
Jab,
and then Josh story,
I'm like out and you know,
I mean,
boom,
boom.
And I'm going again.
He throws get cool,
Eh,
and then,
uh,
he's a big dude.
He's a big dude,
sorry,
fearing for my life.
Just,
just tapping a light to the room.
And then,
uh,
we do two rounds.
After two rounds,
he takes his glove off and he throws it across the room.
He takes his Shin Pad off,
throws it across the room,
he packs his bag,
he storms out,
and then,
uh,
they go into Tokyo the next day to fight on the New Year's Eve,
um,
pride tournament.
I'd,
I forget who it was against.
Um,
and then about a week passes,
um,
Josh loses his point.
I get a phone call from Eric Paulson about three or four days later,
once,
once I get back and I said,
oh,
I'm a hey,
this is Eric,
you going,
um,
I just want to let you know that we blame you on Joshua's loss because he was
fine right up until he spied you.
And then some kid that had never seen before owned him in the sparring and took
away all his confidence.
So when he got to Japan,
he was a mess.
And this is a true story.
I kid,
you know,
well first of all,
how ridiculous or they to take a guy like you where they don't always just that
new guy in the gym.
It's like,
oh,
I used to buy him a,
okay,
that's ridiculous to do that.
That's the one of the problems with high level MMA as opposed to like high level
boxing.
Could you imagine Floyd Mayweather preparing for a fight and not knowing the
training partner training partner goes in,
it turns out to be some fucking unbeatable world champion boxes of mop and fucks
him up right before our big fight.
Yeah,
you'd never would happen.
And 80 80 he like he'd versus 130 kilo goy and then he's fighting on pride,
which he shouldn't.
Yeah,
it didn't make sense to me,
but I found it quite amusing.
Thing is kind of amusing,
but I mean I can see it from Josh,
his point of view too.
We had no idea.
No,
no,
no idea.
I mean,
imagine you're expecting just some average guy in the gym that's smaller than
you and then you just run into some multiple time world champion.
It just happened I think,
I think,
sorry,
the day before might've been Jujitsu Day.
So the day before I had,
there was my first ever,
I just know that they had brought my finger,
but it's like,
so you were there getting strangled.
So I went in,
I think cubs,
God.
And then Eric's like,
all right,
go,
go where?
He goes,
try and do something to him.
I don't know what to do.
And then,
um,
I'm putting them on getting tapped every 30 seconds and the next day is more
tidy and all of a sudden I put my Cape on,
I take my shirt off.
I've got a big s on my chest,
I turn into superman in,
um,
yeah,
I light up,
uh,
Josh Barnett and then all of a sudden,
yeah,
he's very cranky.
Yeah.
I would imagine that's one of the things that a lot of fighters who are a really
good at one style have an a chuge issue with his learning.
Like a lot of wrestlers,
they never really developed the ability to strike because they would start
sparring and they would get fucked up and they'd be like,
I hate this.
I just want to take these guys down.
That's what I do.
Or a lot of Jujitsu guys,
they didn't want to learn how to kickbox are a lot of strikers.
They just didn't want to learn Jujitsu.
It's
just like we were saying,
you're a world champion and then you would go in there and you wouldn't know
what to do and he didn't like it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It wasn't mine.
And then the whole thing,
for me personally,
as well as,
um,
in between someone,
another gentleman,
his legs,
it's okay,
push the hips,
wish my hips.
Then it's only one way.
I kind of fuck you.
Way To victory.
Yeah,
I know.
It's weird.
Well,
also I'll dude sweat in your mouth sometimes.
That's sometimes people mounting you in the
rise position things rough north.
South,
north,
south.
Yeah.
Tom.
And then my brother was telling me one of the camps,
he went to one of our boys,
they're gone.
What had dip in his mouth while he's training.
I'm not saying his name.
Kevin Random.
Is it American or American wrestling camp?
Was it Kevin?
Random middle of someone?
I'm not sure it was Randleman had dip.
Okay.
But um,
yeah,
they um,
had declined and notice like during a little private lesson with them and the
dip was Cisco.
She's just fucking before I started.
So disgusted.
I know it was.
Yeah.
Well that's the thing about MMA as opposed to like we said,
La Boxing,
like their camps are incredibly organized and they bring in people to mimic a
very specific opponent.
Yes.
They would never have a situation where they just have a class and oh,
a world class fighter is just taking a class with a bunch of strangers that
still exists in MMA.
You know,
and some people think it's a good thing,
you know,
some people think it's,
it's,
it's cute.
Yeah.
But I just think,
you know what you were saying before about George preparing for Johnny
Hendricks,
very specific style and this is the things that will work best against this very
specific stance and style.
I mean,
I think that's the future.
I think when you're dealing with the highest level athletes and combat sports in
MMA,
you're going to have to have these really meticulously designed training camps.
Yeah.
Well
for me,
um,
I watched the,
the,
the [inaudible] and they're coming up and they spend so much time hitting the,
the Toya and with the hammer.
And then they got the robes on this and they're,
they're doing all the sprints with the parachute,
but they come through a straight jab.
Yeah.
Ooh,
those hours spending,
getting fit when you could've spent in the gym.
Just perfecting that,
that stall.
And then I'll get back to Thailand and that the ties don't lift weights.
All they do is hit pads,
run kickback like cavemen.
And it's been for 2000 years.
But it's there.
There's so,
everything's so perfect and their bodies are ripped up.
Men,
I think the myself,
I'd rather look like a tie,
um,
fully ripped and fit than a,
than a half body builder trying to,
trying to pretend I'm a rock,
I'm a wrestler with them.
There's a lot of fighters that believe that there's like sort of a point of
diminishing returns when it comes to strength and conditioning that there's,
but there's a balance that has to be achieved when you're dealing with
grappling,
when you're dealing with a takedowns and the,
the ability to explode and shoot a double a double leg take down.
It's like kicking me.
I think there's certain amount of strength and conditioning is necessary.
I think it's different though.
It's striking.
I think what's striking efficiency of movement,
you know,
the uh,
the,
the also your body becomes accustomed to those techniques.
So you have,
with more efficiency of movement,
you have more,
you lose,
use less energy.
Yes.
And you don't get exhausted.
Whereas you're seeing a lot of these guys that are in great shape,
great strength and conditioning programs.
They're fit,
they're physically strong.
They have a lot of muscle,
but they don't have a lot of physical efficiency in their movements.
When it comes to striking and there they're emphasizing strength.
You see them walk and fucking everything is like wide punches.
It doesn't,
it doesn't look as fluid.
Whereas if you're watching like,
you know,
like yachts and Cli or like you or like bull cow,
you're seeing like a really relaxed,
like the execution is very relaxed.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
And the excess muscle mass that it makes you more tired as well.
Hmm.
Where's your rather be like lean grey hound.
That's um,
but then you got these motherfuckers would take you down,
you know,
and you can't get back up and you get exhausted from the tank downs and you know
that grappling is a different,
it's so different when you add the grappling because like with the way George
beat Bj Penn was so clever because Bj was a very good striker and he's very,
he's wicked with his hand speed.
So George has tied his ass up and made them exhaust his arms.
He just tie and Bj was not known for a guy who concentrate on strength and
conditioning until really after those fights,
after the fight with George,
this when he got,
when he got down with the Mirena bitches and the Marinovich uh,
era of um,
when he was um,
at his best I think was when he was doing maybe why don't I think he's bright.
I think he fought George after that.
I might be wrong.
The best.
Bj Penn though was Bj Penn who went through that Mark Marinovich a strength and
conditioning program cause it was just this unbelievably brutal.
They would show it on the countdown shows.
You just see all the shit that he was doing and he was talking about he couldn't
even hold his kid at night and he going to be so sore and exhausted.
His body was just broken down.
But Mark Burnett Bitch put him in like this insane.
He had it.
He was famous as like a strength and conditioning guy because his son was like
his prodigy and his sun kind of went crazy cause he disciplined him so hard.
He was so like into training on,
but as his son was like a football prodigy from his dad's strength and
conditioning programs and he instilled this program on Bj Penn that he just was
fucking unbelievable.
But what happened out of it,
it was you got this Bj,
you didn't get tired and Bj Penn had so much scale.
He had so much talent and so much heart and determination,
but all of a sudden he has this never ending gas tank,
which you never saw from Bj Penn before.
So in MMA man,
it's like sometimes it's necessary and sometimes it's like trying to find that
balance though.
You have how much skill training and how much strength and conditioning because
all the skill training in the world,
if you get exhausted because you're wrestling with a guy who was a shooting on
you and taking you down all the time,
then I'm going to stay in.
It's almost like MMA has too much going on.
Yeah,
yeah.
It looks like the on the,
on the road to use Shay's,
it looks like someone's take their training here,
then jumping in the car for four hours and something over there.
Then they back over here for two hours remaining in the pool.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It's almost like there's too much going on in a fight too.
It's all,
but that's also what makes it so crazy.
It's like the be the best at that.
You know,
you be the best at that and,
but one of the things you're seeing is the guys that are the best,
they're good at certain things,
you know,
like,
like you don't see Anderson Silva shooting double leg take downs.
Mountain Guy Spinning for armbars mean he's caught a few submissions in his day,
but usually catches him after he fuck somebody up.
Like Dan Henderson.
He fucked him up and then he got his back and choked him.
Or like Chael Sonnen with Chelsea on and just fucked up and late in his garden.
He caught him with a triangle.
But what you're used to seeing him do his kickboxing guy.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's a rumble.
Johnson is perfect example.
He's one of the top contenders at two oh five yeah,
I could see him guillotine.
Anybody.
He's not,
he's not triangle and anybody.
He's stepping forward and blast and people would punches and kicks.
I mean that's what he does and it's almost like to be like the very best is
really hard to be good at everything.
You know,
usually a few guys that are dangerous everywhere.
Like Anthony Pettis is so weird because he's dangerous everywhere.
He's dangerous standing up and then he catch him on his back and he's fucking
catching you in Armbar it's weird.
It's like he's one of the few guys who just dangerous everywhere.
Serone Serona's dangerous,
dangerous off his back,
which is one of the reasons why so willing to kick.
Yup.
Not worried about getting taken down.
You know,
his triangle has armbar all his,
his guard games,
vicious fight with them.
Most jury,
unbelievable.
Oh Dude.
The end when he's throwing those kicks his legs.
But that the first 30 seconds when he went to take a,
when miles went to the taking down and he turned it into a shoulder,
shoulder look,
that was like,
Whoa,
that's pretty high level right there.
He was no joke.
He can do everything.
He's,
I mean I think he's only got a brown belt in Jujitsu,
I think like on paper or whatever,
but the way I,
if I see him move,
it's black belt level.
He's very razor sharp on the ground,
but again,
it's like how many of those guys can do everything?
Like what would,
what would happen if Johnny Hendricks is fighting off his back?
Do you think Johnny Hendricks has a triangle?
Do you think?
You know,
how many times is Robbie Lawler caught a guy in an arm bar and I was like,
the guys like some of the really best guys in the sport,
they're good at a certain aspect of it and then they just concentrate on their
strengths and they use that and they get through and they win.
I wonder what's going to be,
what,
what MMA striking is going to be like five,
10 years from now.
I wonder if you're going to see it ever achieve a level that you're seeing in
like pro Moy Tai.
Yeah.
And then I
do you see yourself working with more MMA fighters?
I have say I really enjoy working with everyone and doing,
moving around train different people.
Um,
and then meeting celebrities like yourself and then,
and doing stuff with you even today was so much fun.
I wish she lived close.
I dealt with every week.
That was fun,
man.
I learned a lot today.
It was really,
I mean it was a short amount of time,
but especially that style of a,
of punching and movement and in combination with kicks and knees.
Yeah.
I believe I'll let the offer when it comes to,
um,
just,
uh,
broadening,
broadening people's idea of how to execute a different strikes.
I want to try and maximize the power edit every single thing that throws it
meant whether it be a hooker uppercut or near a hickey.
I want to try and um,
uh,
destroy anything that a layman would it be for him?
Thawing nose face nick,
that's a very different approach than say like a modern boxing approach or like
you seeing like guys like in corners they'll come back to the corn and the corn
would say just touch him,
touch him with a jab touching.
When there's touching with that.
There's a lot of like guys maybe like Nick Diaz is a good example was throwing
like a lot of punches.
He just touching 30,
70,
but I will say that an intimidation factor.
Also,
if I hit you hard,
you don't want to eat by me again.
I want to just keep chipping it.
If I hit you with a jab that hurts.
Okay,
I'll go.
I just felt off.
I hit you with Lakey.
Okay.
I want to make that really also it gets to the stage where I don't,
I mean you hit the nail and then once I know I'm in your head,
then it makes it a lot easier for me to stop picking things.
Is there a different approach to fighting in a Moitai fight?
Words,
three rounds with no grappling as opposed to MMA,
which is five rounds with,
with grappling and that maybe that sort of style of like so much fucking energy.
Any HUD hard to maintain conditioning for that Michael Johnson last night.
Fuck yeah,
that was amazing.
Damn.
He looked good.
That was awesome.
And he maintained the whole three rounds to 15 minutes.
It just crazy.
Every Michael Johnson man,
he's really looking good these days.
I was cool last night.
It was probably his most impressive performance cause Edson Barboza was a very
good striker.
He just attacked,
attacked like right from the beginning.
Yup.
He's a wrestler.
Yeah.
So another guy just,
you know,
it's just great athlete who is immersed himself.
Yup.
Have you ever trained with Henry,
who's the guy who's the head coach of the coach of the Black Zillions?
No.
Be Interesting to see a hoof does.
He's got a lot of guys down there that he's really improved and in big ways.
He's got that Dutch style.
The Holland Moit are Holland kickboxing style.
He's a teaching these guys showing big improvements too.
And a lot of the fighters.
Yup.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm uh,
I'm here for just the one week and I'm lucky to do a few seminars around town.
So here are the seminars.
If people want to go like what?
You have one on Friday night,
right?
I know you have Friday night,
tomorrow night stepping into the ring.
So tomorrow we got wine at a faction MMA,
which is Gracie [inaudible] cows bad.
It's at six 30 rolls bad California,
California.
And then the next night is at the activate,
um,
the art of eight art of eight limbs.
Weapons.
Yeah.
Celtra where's his place?
That's in Miramar,
also the artist eight sort of convoy road area.
And then a,
so when that was Wednesday night,
Thursday night is that elite training in Redondo Beach?
I think it is.
Um,
and then Friday night is set.
Joseph's,
which is the sub factory.
Which place?
What does the sub factory,
where's that choose?
The North Hollywood won the,
it's one of 'em Eddie's gyms.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
And then Saturday morning is with,
um,
Moitai School of Usi at Saturday morning.
The day of the fights?
Yeah.
At 10:00 AM.
Oh,
great.
Where's that?
Where's the two north Hollywood to,
okay,
cool.
Yeah.
That's a big gym out here,
right?
Yep.
It really big.
They've got a lot of guys coming.
So is there a website where people can go there,
listen to this and didn't get a chance to write it down?
What does it sit on?
We'll just put it on John Wayne Pas a Twitter fan page.
Okay.
John Wayne par fan page on Facebook and John Wayne Parks Twitter account.
All the dates will be up on there and all the times and all that stuff.
Yes.
Beautiful.
Anything else brother?
Um,
if you get an opportunity,
I'll have a documentary that's I've just released on Youtube.
It's called blessed with venom.
Uh,
it's a 90 minute documentary when it was at least in Australia.
It had a two weeks in the cinemas and then the company that put it out for me,
uh,
once it was finished,
they sorta lost my phone number and I didn't hear anything from him for like
three or four years.
So now I thought,
you know what,
fuck you,
I'm putting it on Youtube for free.
So if anyone wants to see it,
it's a,
it's a lost your phone number.
Literally lost your phone number or they just stop going and stop calling me.
They were going to do DVD sales.
I don't know what happened to that base.
I was getting messages from people in Brazil and we've just watched the
documentary and Mizzou with them.
Subtitles.
Absolutely amazing documentary.
And I'm thinking where's all this money going there actually wouldn't have gave
it to the Brazil TV for free.
Uh,
I didn't,
I didn't make 1 cent from,
from the documentary,
so I thought it got to the stage with these people just so nobody else has to,
oh,
I don't want to let them know.
Hey there.
But they know who they are.
Yeah.
But it was amazing.
I can't thank them enough for making the documentary.
So,
but now it's on youtube for free.
So if anyone wants to watch it,
it's called blessed with venom and it's going to Thailand visiting my old camp,
uh,
interviewing yards and glow and other tiny opponents.
I'm San Angelo.
Uh,
the traditions about going to finding it penis stadium and just lots of
highlights of old flights.
I watched it this morning.
It was pretty fucking bad ass.
Hey,
it's really cool.
Nice.
And then that'd be cool having a documentary on you like that.
Yeah.
And when you still alive too and when I'm not bullshit.
That was when it was released in cinemas to the,
the first night there premiered it had a red carpet and we had a 450 people in
the cinema.
And then I play my mom,
my mom and my Nana and the family together.
And it was uh,
the,
my,
my head was three stories high.
He was,
he was such
a,
such a cool buzz.
Wow.
One of those things where you pinch yourself,
you can't believe this is happening.
So pronounced on Youtube.
Say It's,
it's pretty cool.
It's,
um,
and then if you don't know much about [inaudible] and you want to find out about
the culture,
it's a,
this is the perfect documentary.
Did they realize it?
We're not bad.
Guys are not thugs.
We're just,
I'm just,
every day guy is trying to make it in a sport where it involves punching other
people in the face.
Well,
your,
your people that are involved in a very unusual quest,
the quest to get excellent at using your limbs to fuck up.
Other dudes were really good at using their limbs and fuck up.
I mean,
it's,
it's about as exciting a sport and as exciting and endeavor as you could
participate in it.
You know,
it's beautiful man.
And it was an honor to have you on here honored and train with you.
You know,
I mean,
you're,
uh,
in,
in my world,
you're,
you're a huge star.
Hey.
You know,
and you've always been a big name in,
in Moitai and kickbox.
So it was cool to meet you and I met you at the UFC and it was cool to do this,
man.
I really,
really appreciate it.
Hey,
I have no idea how much it means for me to watch you on,
um,
from the UFC every single weekend and then did to talk to you on Twitter.
I think a little bit of we come out when you're talking to me that the first one
there is so cool.
And then to have a relationship,
we have a relationship and I've traveled for all the way from Australia to
arrive here yesterday.
To actually sit in front of across EMEA and to be in this room is,
um,
so surreal and so amazing.
Let's do it again,
man.
Let's do it again.
Tell me when you going to be back here again.
Beautiful.
I'll,
I'll be in touch.
Yeah,
let's set it up.
Let's set it up and try to set up some seminars too.
Maybe we can connect with some people that would like to do more seminars out
here in America and John Wayne,
mother fucking barley's gem.
His actual name is Wayne par,
just so you know,
they seek,
they made him go by John Wayne pump,
but they call you John will in John will in in Thailand,
Thailand,
Thailand.
All right,
brother.
Thank you very much,
man.
My pleasure.
Thank you.
Ooh,
okay.